these titles in bookstores this coming
week and watch for many of the authors
in the near future on book tv on c-span
too
good morning everyone welcome to the
gordon current science and technology
center here at the museum of science
boston my name is eric my pronouns are
he him and this is a very special guest
event we have a guest speaker
richard munson who's here to talk about
his brand new book just came out this
week called tesla inventor of the modern
who's heard of nikola tesla we're going
to hear all about his life and his
accomplishments and his inventions from
the author himself so please join me in
welcoming richard munson thanks very
much appreciate everybody um
[Applause]
tesla is getting um i'm glad so many
people know a little bit about him he
has become sort of a um there's been a
modern revival of him um larry page who
was google's you know co-founder
recently came out and referred to tesla
as the hero
that he has had
probably most people when they think
about tesla they now think about elon
musk's car and battery and solar
equipment but i today want to talk sort
of more about the man and the process
that i went through over the last to be
honest four years writing this book um
and i thought i'd um offer some
uh insights from my perspective like
four of them that i thought were just
kind of key to
surprises that i had and possibly
surprises to you as well the first is
just the extent
of this man's genius
i mean this man invented the electric
motor he invented the
long distance distribution of
electricity according to the united
states supreme court he invented radio
he did a remote control he did robots
the list goes on and these are the very
basics of our economy were done by one
single man there was a quote by the
american institute of um
electrical engineers that said were we
to seize and eliminate from our
industrial world the results of mr
tesla's work the wheels of industry
would cease to turn our towns would be
dark
and it's not only the things that he did
in his life but he had this fantastic
imagination he was able to envision
things and sort of outline what they
would look like even if the technology
wasn't available then for him to be able
to make it he foresaw cell phones radar
laser weapons artificial intelligence
vertical lift aircraft the list sort of
goes on one of the quotes that really
knocked me out on a cell phone this guy
about 110 years ago was talking about
the ability to have something in your
best pocket which would give you news
and he said we shall
see and hear one another so perfectly as
though we were face to face despite
intervening distances of thousands of
miles and a man will be able to carry
one of these in his best pocket this 105
years ago he comes up with this little
play-up so
as a visionary um he was quite
remarkable i should admit however that
um this man also came up with some
um quixotic
notions that um you could say either
complicate his legacy or make him more
interesting
he spent years trying to figure out how
to communicate with intelligent beings
on other planets
he spent years trying to figure out how
to read your mind by putting little
monitors in your retina
so here's a guy that he had great
success he missed several things he
thought of some things that were totally
wrong but for an inventor he had a
really amazingly high batting average of
getting things right
the second thing my day job is that i
work for the environmental defense fund
and i do clean energy work um in chicago
and another surprise to me was that
nikola tesla was actually a clean energy
pioneer his first major article was in
the year 1900 in something called
century magazine which at the time was
the largest circulation
newsletter of its kind and that was
called the subtitle was how to capture
the sun's energy and so 118 years ago he
was describing in great detail how you
can capture energy from the sun and the
wind
um
as an environmentalist i keep thinking
sort of mixing my day job and my writing
job what a wonder it would be
to be able to have nikola tesla alive
here today
so that he would think outside of the
box particularly at the electricity
industry that he helped create which has
become a little bit stodgy because it's
been monopolized for many years and it's
risk-averse and sort of innovation
averse but imagine what he could do he'd
be thinking about ways to send
electricity wirelessly he'd be thinking
about ways to generate electricity
without pollution he'd be thinking about
ways of sending electricity to everybody
around the world including the two
billion people today that still don't
have electric power he was in fact a
magician
he would give presentations and this was
sort of his view electricity is still
sort of a wonder that to be honest
physicists don't really still understand
exactly what it is but we know that it
works it keeps our beer cold it keeps
our you know computers running it
it's a wonder he somehow or another
captured and was able to
control this wonderful resource
he would create lightning
this was something that had been
reserved for nature alone
he was able to make globes glow even
though they were not connected to any
wire
this was a
quite a remarkable individual the um
i guess my third surprise
is to uh present
this guy's struggle between the present
and the future
you could call it apocryphal you could
call it weird you could call it
appropriate but he was born
during a
intense lightning storm at the very
stroke of midnight between the 9th and
10th of july 1856. how weird is that
this became the this birth story became
sort of the part of tesla family lore
and he as a result sort of felt that he
had some special qualities i mean this
doesn't happen to everybody i as a
biographer looked at this and it
explains i think a lot about him because
this was a man that was sort of stuck
between
focusing on today and looking at the
future and he was always trying to sort
of balance
the realities of the present
and then spending time envisioning what
the future might look like let me give
one example the year is 18
um
1897. he had just
completed
capturing the immense power from niagara
falls
um and he was able to put it through a
series of generators
and distribute that electricity first 26
miles to buffalo new york and then an
amazing 400 miles all the way to new
york city just to give you some sense of
how
unbelievable that is thomas edison's
approach to sending electricity which
was called direct current could only
send something for about a half a mile
what tesla invented using alternating
current he sent 400 miles the new york
times referred to this as the
technological
accomplishment of the 19th century and
they said to tesla
belongs
as the man who made this project
possible there still is a statue that
commemorates uh his work there
but this is you know 1897. he just did
this
and he's thinking this is so today
i am bored with today um i
this is a real accomplishment i want to
think about something new so he decided
i'm going to create a whole new field of
science he referred to it as
telemetonics we would today refer to it
as robotics
his first piece of equipment was a model
boat
it's about four feet long about three
feet high
um and this was
at a time
um he presented it in some flashy
places at madison square gardens the old
madison square garden in new york and he
set up there
a pool or a pond in the middle of this
exhibition area to demonstrate um this
material recognize that this is about
three months after the battleship maine
had exploded in the havana harbor so we
were just at the beginning of the
spanish-american war there was a lot of
interest in trying to figure out are
there new ways of making weapons
and so he has this presentation he
brings in the navy he brings in
inventors other inventors scientists
journalists
and for about 15 minutes he has this
little model boat
going forward going back
dancing like a water bug sort of going
around
the pond and basically everybody's
sitting there you know you read some of
the comments from the newspaper reports
afterwards some people were saying it
was you know controlled by a tiny little
monkey was inside that was trying to
move it around other people thought that
it was haunted um
but
what he then did after mesmerizing
everybody he sort of turned to the crowd
and said
would anybody like to ask the boat a
question
and everybody sort of you know has this
blank look on their face what do you
mean ask the boat a question and so some
probably math nerd comes up and says all
right what's the cube root of 64.
and tesla he's standing there in the
back he's got his hand underneath sort
of a secret panel
and he flips a button four times that
flashes the light on the uh the model
boat and as he said the crowd went nice
because they were thinking there has to
be a monkey inside there there has to be
something but this was his sort of
conflict between the realities of today
he just did a major probably the major
engineering accomplishment of the 19th
century and that bored him
what is remarkable is uh hit of his
accomplishment is that marconi
who gets the credit for radio in in
people's popular mind he tried to do
something just like this about three
months later he brought out a little
boat and he had pretended that there was
a spanish frigate on the other side of
the pond that he would maneuver his
little boat up there and then he had
placed a little tiny bomb so we would
blow up the spanish frigate again
remember we're at the beginning of the
spanish-american war
so he gets his boat maneuvers it over to
the spanish frigate punches the button
nothing happens
the frigates do it fight and suddenly
there's a huge explosion in the back
room because he had not figured out how
to individualize messages and so the
message went back to the storeroom that
had been storing marconi's bombs and
blasts and smoke come pouring out into
the area now for tesla he looks at this
and he thinks big i mean
so
you know some reporter asked him is you
know is this a model boat
or is this a submarine that's able to
deliver you know bombs and he was aghast
are you kidding me
he said this is the first
non-biological form of life
it is embodied with a mind
his
and
his view of this was that um
he foresaw artificial intelligence
and then went on to say
that um the boat would be able to follow
a course laid out or obey commands given
far in advance but it may be capable of
distinguishing between what it ought and
what it not what it ought not to do this
is artificial intelligence or at least
the beginnings of it again almost 100
years ago
today my fourth surprise
of this was you know everybody when they
talk about not everybody but a lot of
the articles about nikola tesla make him
appear to be a superman one biographer
said that he was
like a supernova in the of the human
race
and you know to be fair
you know inventing the electric motor
long distance electricity robots remote
control radio those are pretty super
uh accomplishments but the part that
intrigued me was that he was also a
human and charmingly so
um one of the great benefits of being a
biographer is every now and then you get
to be surprised about things i was
surprised one day when i was at the
library of congress and i asked the
librarian there you know what they had
on tesla and he says oh
oh i've got a whole bunch of boxes in
the back and in those boxes were these
letters
that tesla had been writing to his
friends or to his colleagues or his
business associates suddenly you got to
see this man in reality of upfront so he
had lots of friends to be quite honest
um his closest friends were robert um
and catherine johnson robert was the
editor of the century magazine which we
discussed before
catherine his wife ran an intellectual
salon at their townhouse in the murray
hill district of manhattan
and they were not particularly rich but
they acted that way and they brought
together for dinners artists musicians
you know other luminaries one who came
all the time
you know if you recognize this gentleman
this is mark twain
he would come to dinner and after dinner
would go to tesla's laboratory
and that's nikola tesla there in the
background and these two buddies to be
quite honest they played like kids
they were shooting lightning beams
across the lab they were making globes
glow they were having a marvelous time
and i guess um
my point here is that this man this
superman which i'm willing to say did
super accomplishments the intriguing
part was that he was human there's this
is that was both robert and catherine
again um one example of their letter um
he
uh tesla had been sick with a cold for a
couple of days so robert wrote him a
letter which i think just you know
exemplifies their daily notes that they
sent to each other about their health or
their writings
and it said it's been a whole week since
we saw you and you need cheering up come
as early as possible and get cheered we
are in a jolly mood and the fire is
lighted on the hearth and we only need
you
so this very human superman i think just
to conclude
sort of reveled in the excitement of
discovery this was at his core he said i
do not think there is any thrill that
can go through the human heart like that
felt by the inventor as he sees some
creation of the brain unfolding to
success
such emotions make a man forget sleep
food friends love
everything
what's interesting about tesla i think
as an inventor he was perhaps one of the
last curiosity driven inventors
motivated by idealism
whereas thomas edison invented um
largely
practical products so that he could make
money there's nothing wrong with that
it's no criticism whatsoever but tesla
he felt that
even though you know it's not like he
didn't like money he enjoyed his meals
at del monaco's um he enjoyed his nice
apartment at the waldorf astoria but he
felt that technology transcended the
marketplace
that invention was more important than
simply profits
so
he no doubt
i think aimed high
perhaps higher than any other inventor
we've had in this country and i guess
part of my reason for writing this book
is to give him more
credit and exposure than he has gotten
i'm not trying to criticize you know
edison or marconi they did amazing
things but tesla did as well
and
these are a few pictures of him as he
you know just ages you get some sense of
him but like um
he through his idealism he thought that
he would you know bring power to
everyone around the world freely he
thought he would create robots that
would eliminate drudgery
he basically was driven by inner forces
that
felt that sheer creation was the most
important thing in the world and i would
argue that we all are the better for it
so thank you very much
okay we have time for just a few
questions if anybody has questions about
tesla for our guest author yep
hi um
in your book it seems like you speak a
lot of his brilliance but do you mention
any of his uh
eccentricities
oh he made a lot of mistakes
i mean he for instance not long after um
the wright brothers flew their airplane
he came out and said airplanes aren't
going to make it they can't possibly
soar they're too heavy
and so he said that count zeppelin's um
you know dirigible that was the way to
go
relative to einstein who was two decades
younger than he was um
tesla thought that he had split an atom
and that no energy came out so he said
you know atomic power is bunk it just
won't work he thought that cosmic rays
could go faster than
the speed of light so he got things
wrong but i guess my point was that his
batting average was really really good
um all inventors if they're you know out
there on the cutting edge are going to
make mistakes i mean edison um thought
that he had a brilliant new ways for
increasing the efficiency of um
extracting ore from rocks it failed all
inventors fail my point is that you know
uh tesla you know had a better battering
average than most and what he gave us
through motors and electricity and radio
and robots are at the very core of our
um economy and at least i for one and
grateful that we had him
any other questions
yes sir
how did he do financially
well that's a very good question
he
he went up and down is the short answer
his first job um was working in paris
and budapest installing um edison phone
systems he then got to come to the
united states to work for edison himself
edison paid him a tiny little bit of
money in fact he quit because there was
a squabble about money and then he got
cheated by his
partners in a new business and he
actually spent a year digging ditches
making two dollars a day
and then suddenly he sells his um
electric motor patents to george
westinghouse the pittsburgh um
industrialist and suddenly he's wealthy
i mean
really wealthy and he moves into the
waldorf astoria eats every dinner at del
monaco's but then in the um after he and
westinghouse did the niagara falls
project westinghouse was a little bit
stretched and j.p morgan
ruthless banker that he was went after
trying to take over westinghouse's
company and westinghouse then had to
turn to tesla
who had this contract to get a royalty
for every horsepower of a motor that
came out which was worth billions of
dollars
and westinghouse says to him i'm about
to lose my company you know um
can you help me and tesla
unbelievably horrible businessman and
negotiator that he was says
you've always been kind to me you are
the one who is going to bring my ideal
of this great electric motor to the
world let me tear up my contract
he gave away a billion dollars
and so for the rest of his life he
struggled and to be honest he died a
poor man alone in the hotel new yorker
and supporter had declared bankruptcy
and was supported only because a few
scientists at um the westinghouse
company who realized that he had
actually made the company possible gave
him a little stipend so that he had a
room at the hotel new yorker that was a
long answer but it was up up and down is
on on the money front
any other questions
i'd like to know what do you think in
our modern times if tesla was able to
see the modern world and all the
technology that we've used do you think
his reaction would be surprised do you
think it would be proud
i think he'd still be looking at the
future i mean so um thinking of just you
know totally new ways of doing things so
i mean he probably looked at the cell
phone and said yeah i thought of that um
and then
sort of move on and think you know well
maybe i really can think of a new way of
sending lightning bolts into the earth
taking advantage of the earth's natural
electricity getting some resonance or
echo and then make electricity available
to everybody in the world so you could
simply plug a plug into
the earth outside you know your home and
you have it so
i i think i come back to this balance
between him
making the reality of today uh and being
happy about it but always sort of
thinking that that's not enough he has
to be thinking about tomorrow
please
from the uh
so tesla might be sort of impressed at
the technology today
what would he think of the march for
science and and
some of that
outcome of the most recent election as a
reflection in science and society
well
he viewed himself and he was proud to be
a scientist
and
so i think any attack on the ability to
think creatively would have abhorred him
it just could not um have fathered him
he wasn't much of a political person he
got involved every now and then but
didn't do anything i in my mind i think
the interesting thing that he would look
at today
is how the inventing process happens
which is in my view and i think in his
would be it's mostly done now by teams
and you know so either teams out of
universities you know corporate research
labs
um
you know well
i was at a conference the other day and
they were they were talking about a
research project and they had 165 people
on this project this is mind-boggling he
was an individual inventor and we sort
of have lost that and i think he would
sort of lament in trying to be figuring
out how do we create a culture by which
we allow
individuals with their crazy ideas and
their great ideas to be able to flourish
and not necessarily push them into a
team this is not a criticism of the team
approaches obviously giving us great
things but i think
i would guess he would lament the loss
of the individual inventor
yes
after he came to
the um
the united states did he go back and
forth or was he strictly not very often
he did a couple of times he went back
once to give speeches and to protect his
own patents
in both london and then in paris and his
mother died while he
was back there but no he spent most of
his time in the united states and
actually most of that even in new york
city um which was you know sort of his
core of of where he worked he loved
being in his laboratory i mean that was
his favorite place he had a few
assistants but um he this that was
clearly managed by him
and
again what came out of that laboratory
was
the foundations of our modern economy
all right richard will be here for a few
more minutes if you'd like to come up
and say hi very much please join me in
thanking him one more time for talking
today
if
if i might um if you are interested in
the book i'm i'm supposed to promote my
book you can go to tesla
dashbook.com and there's information
with the reviews and other speaking
engagements and order forms so i
appreciate your interest in mr tesla and
thanks very much for your attention
[Applause]
book tv is on twitter and facebook and
we want to hear from you tweet us
twitter or dean and republican national
committee chairman ed gillespie
[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
historian jill jones she joins us to
discuss her recent book empires of light
edison tesla westinghouse and the race
to electrify the world
[Music]
jill jones author of empires of light
edison tesla westinghouse and the race
to electrify the world
why did you write this book
well i was actually reading an old
biography of george westinghouse
and
there are several chapters devoted to
this war of the electric currents
and
what
caught me was this description
of thomas edison
and how he helped
develop and promote the first use of the
electric chair as a tactic to smear
westinghouse who was his rival
in this race this very bitter
business rivalry and corporate feud as
to who
would dominate this nascent
electrical industry that they the two of
them were
racing to develop
and i i just found that so astonishing i
i thought of edison
as
really a benevolent genius kind of a
folksy and wonderful person
this was a dark side of him that i had
really didn't know
and when i looked into the rest of the
story i just find it so compelling this
the idea of a world in which there
wasn't electricity
was a very
fascinating idea as a historian to try
and take you back to that time
and then
develop
this wonderful
set of characters as they
really struggled
to
make electricity a common place
how'd you go about it
well um
i think the way you research most
history you start by looking at books
other people have written
and there are lots of books about edison
a few books
a few books about nikola tesla who's a
key character in this because he
develops the alternating system of
electricity which we use to this day
and then george westinghouse
was a very famous pittsburgh
corporate warrior and but with him there
were really only these two old
biographies so he was actually
the most elusive of the three
time frame for the book
the book really starts in 1879 when
edison has invented the light bulb
and it ends in 1897 when they celebrate
the first transmission
of alternating current electricity 26
miles from niagara falls
to buffalo and that's really the
beginning of the electric grid which
just collapsed
in the summer
in 1879 how much electricity was there
in the united states very little
there was electricity
that was um
basically run off of batteries and that
ran the telegraph a very small number of
telephones
and there were also starting in the very
early 1880s something called arc lights
and those did run off of generators in
fact alternating current generators and
they were a very
brilliant
almost kind of sizzling form of light
they functioned by having these two
carbon pencils and the electricity kind
of jumped between them and that
created this very
almost um
painful to look at light so they would
it could only be used in extremely large
spaces or outdoors and so you would have
in a city a very tall pole almost like a
mast of a ship and at the top of that
would be these arc lights and that would
light up big public spaces
homes lighted anywhere in 1879
not with electricity
what edison
boasted to the world that he would do is
he would subdivide the light and what he
meant by this was the electric light
that now was so brilliant and bright in
public spaces
what most houses had if they were in a
city was gaslight and what this meant is
that gas came into your house through
pipes and came to every fixture and you
had to turn it on and light it which
meant usually you had to take off the
glass globe
otherwise what people had were kerosene
lamps which i think most of us are
familiar with still from camping and so
forth
um
and candles
that was what you lit your house with
now you start this book by defining
things like volts amps ohms
well ohms is a law uh volts
is a term of pressure it's you know the
number of volts gives you an idea of the
pressure that's sending the electricity
out
amps is actually just the amount of
power and then resistance is electricity
goes out generally on a copper wire and
that
substance is creating a resistance to
the electricity as it travels on it and
so
the way you calculate uh how much
electricity is going out as a function
of of these three
um
i guess uh terms the reason i mentioned
those three they were all three people
exactly who who was volta well volta was
the first man he was an italian count to
create a functional battery
and
one of the things that was fun about
doing these books is
learning the people behind the names
and
he
put together a battery that would be
alternating
discs of
zinc and copper and in between would be
a saturated
um like thick paper
and
he then put in various saline solutions
and once these things all got going they
created electricity because before that
the only way you could
manufacture electricity was through
something called an electrostatic
machine and you would rub this and it
would
the rubbing would create electricity
which you then would capture in a laden
jar
and it would stay there maybe for a few
days and if you
touched the jar big jolts of electricity
would come out and so
i have a chapter that
describes this very early of electric
early history of electricity you know
starting with amber you
rub amber and you get a
electrostatic charge and that was really
the first clue
that there was this invisible energy
that could make things happen but
how did you harness it and how did you
come to understand it because it is
invisible
who is ampere
well ampere uh was a very brilliant
french mathematician and really what he
did was just to
create
some
mathematical understandings of
electricity as it was being developed so
he was
essentially developing formulas who was
ohms
ohm was a german and he was the man who
came up with ohm's law which is volts
equals amps times resistance
so there you have an italian a frenchman
and a german right and then there's a
guy named kelvin i i don't know much
about electricity and all but there
isn't lord kelvin he was originally
known as sir william thompson and what
he was most famous for
was um helping to lay the atlantic cable
and make it work between england and the
united states and and that was a
a huge accomplishment and he also um
oh created
figured out all kinds of aspects again
of the the physical nature of
electricity and he plays a a very
important role in one aspect of the war
of the elected currents who else is in
this picture
well to the left of lord kelvin is
george westinghouse and we don't know
who's to the right but there are
all in at westinghouse's
factory in pittsburgh
and um
i should say that
westinghouse was a man who had very few
photos
i guess it's it's kind of indicative of
the different personalities here that
westinghouse
i don't think there's probably even 20
photos of him as opposed to someone like
edison who was enormously
famous celebrity and beloved of the
press
there may be thousands of photos of
edison but there's certainly hundreds
thomas alva edison
what can you tell us about him
well
he was a wonderfully interesting man he
was obviously our greatest inventor he
still remains so he has more than a
thousand patents
which remains the record for any one
american inventor and at this particular
moment he had already invented the
quadruplex telegraph he was very famous
for that
um
even more astonishing because it was
completely original he had invented the
uh talking phonograph
and so as he and he had many smaller
kinds of inventions but those were his
two really big ones and that he had
become very wealthy from and so
as we start this book in 1879 a friend
has convinced him that he should get
interested in electricity and takes him
off to see some arc lights
um at a factory in
connecticut where is he living then
he's opened his so-called invention
factory in menlo park new jersey which
is a very bucolic
uh rural spot so that all
his feeling is that he's brought all his
men and
equipment and machines out from newark
and this way they can really work
completely unimpeded or unbothered by
anything and it's right on the
pennsylvania railroad line so that
people can get back and forth very
easily
um
and once he sees these arc lights he is
set a fire with ambition he thinks
this
is the future and it's just starting and
i still have a chance and he's not
interested in arclights to him that's
something that's very limited because
it's only going to be in the public and
in big spaces he wants to subdivide the
light and he rushes back to menlo park
and he starts working
on inventing a
functional incandescent light bulb
because
for decades various inventors uh on the
continent in the united states have been
trying to figure out how to do this
and edison has this incredible innate
sense of pr and he's very beloved of the
newspapers because he has this
folksy persona
wears these blue workman's outfits and
he's always covered with grease and he
kind of
makes these uh very amusing remarks so
the press loves him and uh within a week
after having visited uh
the the arclight inventors up in
connecticut he's summoned a reporter
from the new york sun to announce that
he has he has prevailed he has invented
an incandescent light bulb
and that's not all he's announcing he's
announcing that he is going to
bring electricity to lower manhattan
he's going to have a central station
that operates a big generator and he's
going to kill off
gas in america
so he's made a very
large claim for himself when did he
start becoming deaf
he was actually a deaf his definite
began even as a teenager and i have a
little story in the book which he told
different stories over time but
paul israel who's
one of the sort of top
scholars of addison
finds this the most plausible which is
that he worked as a young man um
on the railroad starting at about age 12
and selling newspapers and he was trying
to get onto a train and not making it
when one of the conductors reached down
to get him and pulled on his ears
and he said from that moment on his ear
never was quite the same and he wasn't
completely deaf i mean that his deafness
got worse but one of the endearing
aspects of edison is he's such an
optimist about everything and so to him
even his deafness was an advantage
because it
kind of sealed off a lot of the
distractions of life there's a picture
of him in the book taking a nap why did
that make it to the book
well that was very typical of edison he
was a real workaholic he loved what he
did and he would get completely caught
up in his work
and
then all of a sudden he'd be exhausted
and he would take a nap but under a
table um
you know on top of a chair
it just and so when i saw that picture
which actually is in the smithsonian at
an exhibit i thought i really want to
have that
where was he from originally
married children
well he grew up in michigan
really his mother ran a rooming house
his father was
not very successful
man who'd tried various trades
and edison was very much self-taught
he taught himself to be a telegrapher
and he became the best telegrapher and
it was really that that got him into
inventing he was trying to figure out
how to make telegraphs work better it
was also how he knew quite a bit about
electricity
about the time that he moved to menlo
park
he married and had
several small children
and then later
his wife
who i think one could safely say was
very neglected because really what he
was in love with was his work
um
she died and he then married a very
young and lovely woman had some more
children with her i think in the end he
had about five kids um
and that was his married life was he
political at all
he was republican uh but no he was not
very political really his life was his
inventions and
developing them as an inventor he was
completely interested in the commercial
application of whatever he invented
and if he if it couldn't be made
commercial he wasn't interested
before we go on can you describe the
difference between direct current
electricity and alternating current ac
versus dc uh dc the electrons just move
in one straight line
along
the copper wire that is conducting them
and it can't go very far so one of
edison's problems though he didn't see
it as a problem was that his direct
current generators only could send
electricity maybe about half a mile as
they improved maybe three quarters or a
mile
um so his vision when he
thought of electrifying the world was
that there would be an edison generator
about every mile so you can see he was
planning to be very rich
alternating current however
goes along the wire like this it's got a
frequency and it's moving and so it sets
up a little electromagnetic
field around it and when you take
alternating current wires and you wind
them around one another
in a certain kind of a way
you can
increase the voltage
enough that you can send it very long
distances and that was westinghouse's
real
contribution to this
early
field
was that he created a commercial
transformer because that's what they're
called you transform the electricity up
you send it where you want to send it
and there's a transformer at the other
side and with many fewer
coils of electricity and that brings the
electric electrical
electricity down to a you know a level
that's safe for people to then use it in
their uh appliances and have it come in
and light their houses do you have an
electric electricity background of any
kind no i have to say i did not know a
thing about electricity when i started
this book my husband is a scientist and
he
was very amused at the idea that i was
writing a book about electricity where's
your headquarters
i live in baltimore doing what they're
full time i just i'm a historian and i
write books and what book is this for
you
this is book three
uh
there are drawings in here i mean
there's schematics and stuff like that
where did you go to get this kind of
information how did you learn it
well the schematics are
present in many
books that are trying to explain about
electricity because since it is
invisible it helps to have it
laid out for you
and so i found numerous schematics that
i found very helpful because as i say i
knew nothing about electricity
and
had my father-in-law john ross who's an
artist render them for me so that that
would help others who were
learning about the mysterious fluid as
it was called
get some sort of an understanding of
electricity how did you make sure that
you were right about all this i had many
people read the book
did you have to go to experts on
electrical engineers or something like
that or um no i i had uh i mean yes some
of these people were experts obviously
one of the people i had read it was my
husband
what kind of a scientist is he
um he's actually uh a doctor
and a
a neuroscientist and a geneticist
your second person that you talk about
is this fellow right here uh is it
nicola or nico nicola nicola tesla
nicola tesla how old would he have been
in this picture probably about 22.
what's his story well nikola tesla is
truly one of the great characters
um
and i
had heard of him but i really didn't
know that much about him until i started
working on this
and he is a very brilliant serbian
immigrant whose passion
was electricity
and
he
came to paris to work
in the edison factory there
and he had had this great
epiphany even before he arrived in paris
about alternating current what year
would that have been that would have
been
in the
late 1870s
so we're still around 1879. right
so what was it
his epiphany came he came to work for
edison electric
in uh
1882. so as when the pearl street
station gets up and running in manhattan
edison who has visions of a worldwide
empire has already sent his aide charles
bachelor to paris to begin continental
edison and nikola tesla goes there to
work for him and tesla has many strange
phobias one of which he likes to do
everything in threes
um and so when he would start his
morning before he went to to work there
he would go and swim laps at a pool on
the the sand and he always did 27 laps
and when he would walk he would try and
make sure that he didn't walk you know
more than something that was divisible
by three
he had a
horror of germs he couldn't stand to be
in the same room as women with pearls
so
but he was very charming and
very erudite
now edison was really a self-educated
man he read his way through entire
libraries but tesla had a university
education and so he came into this from
a much more educated standpoint
and as i say he had a passion for
electricity and no one had been able to
figure out how you could run a motor on
alternating current
edison used direct current and it was
fine for lights and it was fine for
motors so when he went out to sell his
product to people you know let me bring
electricity into your factory let me
bring electricity into your uh
office he could offer not only lights
but uh
machines
this was not true for alternating
current and tesla
was the one who figured out in his mind
how to create a motor that would operate
on alternating current
and when he went to
work for edison in paris he tried to
convince them that alternating current
was a superior form of technology to dc
but you have to unders imagine the
circumstance
tesla is this very junior engineer he's
a serbian he's a you know kind of a
eccentric fellow
edison is world famous he's created
electricity he's invented the light bulb
he's invented everything that makes the
light bulb work i mean he's
come up with the generators in his um
factory he's come up with all the
the wiring systems the switches it's a
huge accomplishment and so who's to pay
any attention to nikola tesla you know
he just seems like a dreamer
he leaves paris after a couple of years
and goes to new york
still wanting to convince edison that
alternating current is the way to go
and
he can't convince edison edison
for one thing believes that alternating
current is dangerous because it's
operating at these higher voltages and
he really wants nothing to do with it
but there's another aspect to it i
believe which is that edison took
enormous pride in the fact that he had
developed every aspect of this system
and for him the idea of adopting someone
else's technology is superior to his i
think was
a bitter pill and he wanted nothing to
do with it and so tesla quit
and he
was
cottoning on to the american system of
business and decided he was going to be
very practical and so he started
went into business with a few investors
and started an arclight company
and essentially he was cheated
and meanwhile he's still trying to find
someone to take up this uh
alternating current
engine and a better system of uh
transmission called polyface
uh electricity now what about his
personal life did he ever marry he never
married and as very strange as this will
sound his great love in life with a
white pigeon
oh i just happen to have a picture of
that pigeon that you have from this book
right here is this the pigeon
apparently so that comes from the tesla
museum in belgrade
as i say tesla was a very strange man he
had loads of friends he was actually
very prominent in new york society
once he became very famous
but he had a real affinity
only for pigeons and this was a pigeon
that that he particularly loved and
as evidenced there's a photo of it well
near the end of the book and i'll try to
find it
it's almost might be useful to read that
part of him because once you read this
it it
does change your
view of this man
uh this you get this out of john j
o'neill's book now who is he he was a
science editor at the herald tribune and
a great friend and admirer of tesla's
and he wrote the first biography of him
and
to mom to me i mean it was just such a
mesmerizing book because
it's very saturated with tesla and the
person he was
this uh you start by writing say one
evening the elderly almost cadaverous
nicola
tesla told john j o'neill about the
white pigeon while they were sitting and
visiting in the lobby of the hotel new
yorker is that the same hotel new yorker
that's on eighth avenue right now
probably
um quote i love that pigeon
yes i loved her as a man loves a woman
and she loved me
as long as i had her there was purpose
in my life then one night as i was lying
in bed in the dark solving problems as
usual she flew in through the open
window and stood on my desk as i looked
at her i knew she wanted to tell me she
was dying
when the pigeon died something went out
of my life up to that time i knew that
with a certainty that i would complete
my work no matter how ambitious my
program but when that something went out
of my life i knew my life's work was
finished did
john o'neill go on to
describe any more about that what he
said about the
pigeon that was really pretty much what
he had to say and i think john o'neill
was very taken aback
because it was a confession really
from someone he admired an enormous
amount and it's really quite poignant
well do you think he was and this was
near the end of his life
and at the end if i get it right he was
uh he died when he was 86 years old
right in 1943 hadn't he lost his mind or
was this really well i think he was
always very eccentric um and i in many
ways lived in in his own world
the reality with tesla is that he
invented many many things
only alternating current
ever really became a commercial reality
and tesla has a very
fervent following of people who are
fascinated by him because he invented
all kinds of things that as i say never
were commercially developed but were
very prescient for instance um he
invented a remote control
and this was so far he was so far ahead
of everyone that no one knew what to
make of it
um
he developed a huge boat just looked
like a big toy and he could make it you
know using remote control this is eight
you know 1890s
using a remote control he's sending it
around on the water
and people just
it wouldn't occur to them oh well we'll
use this remote control to open and
close doors or to turn things on and off
it just was like magic to them he also
was way ahead on radio when his
entire laboratory burned down tesla was
a man who had many dramatic turns in his
life
and marconi beat him to it how did his
lab burn down
well he shared the lab it was downtown
in lower manhattan
he shared it with a
another factory and this factory
had all kinds of
grease and
flammable stuff around so it didn't have
anything to do with his lab it had
nothing to do with electricity he just
really had the bad
luck to be in a building
that went up in flames because of
another tenant what year would that have
been
that was uh
must have been about 18
95 or 96. but you set it up here that he
was fighting
edison for
ac versus dc right so what happens is
edison has invented the light bulb in
1882 he gets this pearl street station
up and running and you know it's a
a great uh historic accomplishment
september for 1882.
and edison then has all kinds of other
competitors who are basically infringing
on various patents and so he figures
eventually his legions of lawyers and he
had legions of lawyers would fight off
these other people and they would be
gone from the scene and he would have
the electrical world to himself and then
in 1886
so
edison's been up and running for four
years he's expanding all over the place
all of a sudden along comes george
westinghouse now these other people
that
edison
has
as competitors he doesn't take very
seriously because they are infringing on
on his technology
westinghouse is really a different story
he's a very successful
uh very bold pittsburgh entrepreneur he
has two extremely successful companies
plenty of money
and a different kind of technology which
is this alternating current
that
you know gets stepped up on transformers
and stepped down and so imagine that
you're a salesman for edison and you go
into a
fast-growing american city or town
and america is growing fast we're having
record levels of uh immigration and it's
the great era of urbanization
so imagine you go in and you say okay we
would like to to sell you
an electric generator it'll operate all
your lights it'll operate all your
machines but it can't go more than a
mile
the westinghouse people come to the same
town and say we'd like to sell you our
alternating current generator
and as your town grows
we can expand it all you'll need is this
one generating system we can put it on
the outskirts of town because we can
send the electricity in
well who do you think you're going to go
with
now the disadvantage that westinghouse
was had is that he did not have he could
not run motors
he had not met nikola tesla nor had
nikola tesla announced to the world his
great
invention of a motor that operated on
alternating current
so
but already
alternating current
very quickly became a significant
problem in competition for edison now
the irony of all this is that edison
actually also had patents
to
european
developed alternating current and he
could certainly
have incorporated that and in fact
everyone in this company was begging him
to
but as i say he was very stubborn i
think he had enormous sense of pride and
he
clung to the idea that alternating
current was unsafe
and instead
what he decided to do was to use his
enormous prestige and influence to try
and drive a stake
through the heart of anything to do with
alternating current
george
westinghouse was
you say from pittsburgh what kind of
education did he have was he a family
man what was he like personally well he
was
in the end he was actually my favorite
of these three very
compelling idealistic
man very
reserved in public but very charismatic
and dynamic in private
and he had grown up in schenectady his
father operated
an agricultural implements shop his
father also invented things and put them
together so westinghouse had a very
practical you know sort of on the ground
education
he briefly went to college which he did
not like he fought in the civil war um
and
he
made his fortune inventing air brakes
it's hard for us to believe but
when america operated on railroads and
trains
until the air brake came along which was
uh
oh i guess in the 1870s you couldn't
stop a train very easily
it would you had men who would jump off
down from the roof of the train the car
and turn these things to try and slow it
down so the the one legged train men uh
or brakeman was a fixture
of gilded age america until westinghouse
came up with these air brakes so the the
engineer of the train could stop the
train
and so you can imagine he made a great
fortune on this
in part because he was a very very good
businessman
he then also
using electricity developed whole
systems of
signaling for trains so he was really
someone who had made a fortune in the
toughest corporate atmosphere which is
the world of railroads
and now all of a sudden he appears and
when edison heard this he was very
angry he said
tell westinghouse to stick to air brakes
i mean he did thought that electricity
was his arena and stay out and he also
felt he said
as sure as anything westinghouse is
going to kill people with this with his
ac
and edison was very concerned that that
electricity be seen as benign be seen as
safe so that it could
spread widely without people worrying
that it would kill you
married children uh
westinghouse was
totally devoted to his wife unlike
edison who had wives but you know it's
very neglectful of them
he had a very sweet
relationship and marriage with her he
especially set up wherever he was that
there would be a telegraph or a
telephone so that he could speak to his
wife every day no matter where he was
and he had one son with her
difference in age of these three
they're actually um edison and
westinghouse are about the same they're
in their 30s as this whole war of the
electric currents gets going and uh
develops
and um tesla's a bit younger than they
are but not by much so he might be about
30 and they would both be about 35. i
wrote down the three
men and when they died uh george
westinghouse died march 12 19 14 he was
68 right
and edison died in 1931 he was 84
and tesla died in 1943 he was 86.
money
who had the most money along the way in
this process who made the most
i guess both
from electricity the person who made the
most money finally was westinghouse
um and
that is because his technology triumphed
edison certainly made money on
electricity and he had he was backed by
jp morgan and various wall street money
men
but
as the technology took far longer to
develop than they ever expected so you
remember i had mentioned that in 1879
edison announces i'm going to you know
light up manhattan and give the
impression it will be a matter of weeks
or months
well actually it was almost three years
and this was far longer than anyone
expected and there were many many uh
pitfalls and
problems in the end he
edison put up a lot of his own money in
order to develop his his company
but he did have wall street behind him
westinghouse had a lot of his own money
and he had pittsburgh money behind him
um
tesla never had any kind of a successful
company and what happens is so
westinghouse has come on the scene he
started he's announced he's starting his
company it's early 1886
by the end of that year in 1886 they
run their they set up and get running
their first
project which is a department store in
buffalo and what was interesting about
this is this is a hugely historic event
but in typical westinghouse fashion he
says nothing about this to the
newspapers or anyone else when anything
that happens with edison he is full of
ballyhoo everyone knows it's happened
he's boasted about it he's promoted it
he's terrified his you know any
competitors westinghouse is very
you know kind of quiet
and
so around thanksgiving of 1886 um
they run their first alternating current
generator and send
power a distance into this the fanciest
department store in buffalo adam and
meldrum
and
everyone comes to see this
and it's you know quite an
accomplishment
and that's the beginning but
still westinghouse doesn't have a motor
and in
1886 so almost a year i mean 1888 to
almost a year later is when tesla
finally he's managed to you know get
himself some backers
he has written his patents he's
developed his machines
and he has begun to meet important
people
and he
is
persuaded to go to columbia
college
and before the
his the world of professional engineers
deliver a lecture and demonstrate all of
his machines
and this is a sensation i mean everyone
understands immediately that here is a
new electrical titan and that this is in
fact he could be on the level of an
edison
and westinghouse who's heard about this
even before it happens
immediately swoops in and buys those
patents because westinghouse
is very willing to he himself is an
inventor westinghouse and he always
remembers how much trouble he had when
he was trying to convince people to
underwrite the air brake
to
financing so he's very generous to
inventors of any kind he swoops in he
buys tesla's patent he brings him to
pittsburgh and the whole electrical
fraternity is kind of a buzz because
now westinghouse is going to have what
he has lacked in his fight
with uh edison
and that is the motor
is that is this all public at the time
is it talked about in the newspapers oh
yes very much so is it of interest to
the public at large hugely interest of
interest because this is this era the
gilded age at the end of the 19th
century when people are enormously
interested in technology of every kind
technology has changed the world so
dramatically already there's a sense
that everyone is in the middle of a
continuing revolution
you look at railroads first of all
they've eliminated space in a way or
distance in a way nothing else has that
telegraph has done it even more so when
you think
i i give in my book the example of
jpmorgan because it used to be to hear
from their office in london would take
weeks
now it takes seconds so there's this
tremendous sense of the world shifting
under your feet and becoming smaller and
closer and when people look at the
fortunes that were made from things like
railroads and telegraph they're very
interested in a technology that's going
to
light up the world
not with a flame but you know with
something
the mellow light of an italian sunset
was one description
um and also that's going to
run machines
one of the things that was so
interesting about working on this book
was trying to recreate the world without
electricity this world where you got
everywhere either
you know on a horse
or on a railroad or on a boat or
on your feet
and then also where
just the rhythms of daylight were so
much more a part of people's lives and
that there weren't machines anything i
mean there were steam engines but most
ordinary people did not have machines in
their lives so almost anything you did
was just pure human power or horsepower
one of the things that comes out of your
book is the way that uh thomas edison
treated dogs
well this takes us to the beginning of
the war of the electric currents and the
war of the electric currents is a battle
that went on
um
really you know over a period of almost
uh well i guess you could say probably
about
just under 10 years and it begins
with
edison deciding that he's
going to change his mind about how he
feels about capital punishment he had
always stated publicly that he was
against it
and promote
not only capital punishment but capital
punishment of a very specific sort
electrocution and not only electrocution
but electrocution using alternating
current generators from the westinghouse
company
and
i i date the beginning of the war of
electric currents to december
8
um
1887.
so
westinghouse's company's been up and
running for almost two years his first
successful
uh client this department store in
buffalo was a year previous
and we we don't really know what
set edison off on
this
decision to really
launch what i consider the most vicious
and macau perfume in american corporate
history
but something had happened and he
changed his mind and he
now not only endorsed this idea
but helped actively to promote it um
and one of the ways that he did this is
a very strange fellow named harold brown
sort of steps out of nowhere and begins
attacking westinghouse and as far as any
anyone's been able to figure out this he
was self-appointed sort of anti-ac
warrior
but he was wonderful um
convenience for edison who was
happy to do whatever he could to help
him and eventually actually put him on
his payroll secretly
and so
harold brown needed to
show scientifically
that alternating current should be taken
up by the new york state death
commission as opposed to anything else
any other kind of electricity so he
began going out to edison's
edison now had a new bigger and more
wonderful
laboratory out in west orange he left
menlo park and he was onto a sort of
industrial scale of uh invention and
west orange is today open to the public
well actually uh yes and it's been
preserved by the national park service
so he goes out there and they buy
dogs from local children and they start
electrocuting dogs and what they're
basically trying to figure out is
how much more quickly you can
electrocute a dog with ac versus dc
and once they've done this then he goes
back into manhattan no one knows this is
going on he goes back into manhattan
and invites the electrical
engineers and
overall fraternity
to
a demonstration he doesn't say what it
is he's going to do and they all
turn out to see this
and he begins electrocuting these dogs
and it's just appalling and
it isn't a convincing
demonstration because he begins by
trying to electrocute them with direct
current and the dogs don't die right
away but obviously they're being
tormented and they're in great distress
um
and does he tell them why he i mean he's
the direct current man why does he well
he wants he wants to show that they
don't die from direct current and then
he's going to apply alternating current
but by the time he
gets to the point that he's going to
apply alternating current the crowd is
in such an uproar because this is so
cruel such a cruel thing to see
that um
he's never he
kills the dog off with alternating
current but it's the same dog he's
giving direct current to he's not able
to complete the full
range of demonstration that he wanted to
make he does do that subsequently and
then when the state death commission is
not 100 convinced edison steps forward
and offers his menlo park
laboratory and at that
demonstration they kill not just dogs
but also a calf and a horse and
this is enough to convince
the
state that yes what they need is some
westinghouse
generators to operate their electric
chairs and harold brown then further
gets himself appointed official new york
state executioner why does thomas edison
want the new york state people to use
the alternate the ac of westinghouse
because he wants it to be known as the
executioner's current
and he wants when someone dies in the
electric chair he wants
the world to think of this as being
westinghoused
and tell the world that he doesn't but
among
the
at headquarters all the the edison
uh
executives are kind of chortling among
themselves and writing back and forth
about you know how wonderful this is
this westinghouse know what he's up to
absolutely and he
um
is doing
he
hires a very famous sort of silver
tongue lawyer named
cochran who's also a politician
because what happens is they've now got
their
method of uh
execution
but
first of all then they have to have
their victim and um
a man known as william kemler who's
referred to as the hatchet fiend
murders his girlfriend in buffalo and he
that's not the name he uses
he starts he's known in buffalo as john
court
but he quickly emerges that his real
name is william kemler
and that he's fled from philadelphia
with his paramour who he has
murdered with an ax and he emerges as
the first person who's going to die in
the electric chair and
westinghouse then proceeds to as far as
we can tell there's no absolute proof
but i mean kemler couldn't afford
someone like burke cochran and there
then ensues this long drama
of
cochrane constantly
challenging and appealing
the use of electricity saying that this
would be cruel and unusual punishment
because no one
could really guarantee that kemler in
fact would be killed on the first
effort and he would then have to be
executed twice what's the date of this
um
this all
begins about
oh the early eight i'd say early 1888
and then
it's lost i mean the the case drags on
and kemmler dies on august 6 1890
and
what
his lawyers tried to show is he brings
people who've been struck by electricity
some of
they're alive i mean obviously many
people not electricity by lightning i
mean obviously many people who are
struck by lightning die but there are
people who are struck by lightning and
they live so his point was that
no one really knew what it would take to
actually kill someone electrocute
someone
but he was not able to convince the
courts and so william kendler was
sentenced to die and became the first
man to die in the electric chair on
august 6 1890 and in fact it was a
terrible botch
they didn't give enough electricity to
kill him and they thought he was dead
and
the 20 or so people assembled to see him
die went up and they realized that he
was still alive people were fainting
it was so
hideous
some people had to go out into the
corridor just you know to be ill
and they gave him a second
much more prolonged jolt of electricity
whereupon he was finished off you
actually have
this paragraph but the blood was
continuing to ooze from kimmel's small
finger wound
his heart still had to be beating the
physicians around the limp figure
recoiled as one yelled in horror great
god he's alive another ordered turn on
the current
see he breathes gasp a third
what was the impact of all this
well it didn't seem to stop continued
use of the electric chair but it did
i think cast some doubt on
you know whether ac was a stone killer
and meanwhile the reality remained
that
westinghouse was selling
his his system of of electricity
with great
leaps and bounds
and um
in fact the the so this is the the first
battle and you can say okay
edison won he managed to get someone
electrocuted with alternating current
and
he and harold brown edison and harold
brown then
began to work the legislatures state
legislatures in order to get alternating
current band
but what they hadn't figured on is that
arclights which had really taken off and
were all over the country
arclights would be banned if you banned
alternating current
and
the the local people who operated the
arc lights would come out and testify it
was very hard for an outsider even one
so prestigious as edison to persuade a
legislator
when
the locals were saying
wait you're going to shut down this
entire industry
so that that was the first battle and i
think you could safely say that yes
edison
won that
but he also lost it because
at this point
his refusal to take up alternating
current
was
really creating troubles for his company
and
his competitors had taken up alternating
current of course westinghouse was busy
stewing all of them because he felt that
this was his technology
and
in the end edison lost his company his
electric company jp morgan who held the
great majority of the stock and sort of
managed it for people
in 1892
looked at
how the edison company was doing looked
at how the thomas houston company was
doing which was run by a businessman
named charles cough and he'd been a very
successful shoe salesman and he turned
out he was a very good uh you know
electrical
company uh
chieftain
and um what he saw was that thomas
houston which had taken up alternating
current as a system that it offered to
his its customers
was making profits of 25
the edison company which did not use
that technology was making profits of
12 percent
and he decided he was going to merge
these two companies and create an entity
called general electric
and
that edison was going to be out
and this was a very very bitter blow to
edison he had
tremendous pride in having it was really
his greatest work
and um
so you and
i mean we because we're almost out of
time you go up to where we are today you
still have the westinghouse corporation
even though it wasn't broadcasting it's
no longer right general electric
and what about tesla is there anything
left from him there's really nothing
left of tesla and since we're almost out
of time let me just say quickly that the
war of the electric currents continued
in two other big battlefields one was
chicago of 1893 the white city
which was an incredible showcase for uh
electricity and that that was another
big battle now it's between ge and
westinghouse and westinghouse really
wanted this
and he
came out of near bankruptcy to arrive in
chicago and essentially just
swooped in and stole that contract from
ge by simply offering a far better deal
and then the next
battleground
was niagara falls again a jpmorgan
enterprise
and who would transmit alternating
current and in this case having the
tesla patents was absolutely the trump
card
and remember ge is jp morgan's entity
you can imagine he desperately would
have liked them to do the niagara
uh power
business but he
in the end
their
electrical
advisors said to them you know this is
a contract which has to go to
westinghouse because the tesla patents
are unique and invaluable and actually
in the end westinghouse had to come to a
patent-sharing agreement with ge because
he was so repeatedly
attacked by them you know on wall street
that he felt like he would lose his
company
in the end these three men
how were they financially
well in the end edison was always rich
in part because he got into the movie
business because of his phonograph
um
and he made lots and lots of royalties
from that
westinghouse had plenty of money he
had 50 000 employees many businesses i
mean he was a real corporate titan in a
way that
edison wasn't because he was
backed by wall street in ways that
edison couldn't be because after that
whole episode with jp morgan losing his
company edison wanted nothing more to do
with wall street
tesla
really
sank into penury i mean was
heartbreaking
he actually had given up his patents his
royalties
in order to save westinghouse's electric
company at some point
because he thought he was on the at the
cusp of a
big
career in which he would have many
patents
many products and many riches and it
just didn't work out that way other
things that he tried to do he never
could commercially develop and so he was
actually
supported in part by the serbian
government and in part or i guess the
yugoslav government and in part by the
westinghouse company but actually not in
a very
munificent way how long did this take
you to do
uh two years what was the toughest part
of it
um i would say learning to understand
how electricity worked
the cover of this book has a photograph
of the f.w woolworth building exactly
where is that
if you stand at city hall in lower
manhattan and you look to your right and
up you would see exactly this
and does it still look like this today
oh yeah just as magnificent do they
light it like this today you know that i
don't know i guess i haven't been in low
i go to manhattan a lot but i guess i've
been down at city hall to see it but i
wouldn't surprise me what's next for
jill jones
well it's another gilded age book but i
don't want to say too much more than
that also business and technology the
fellow that endorses your book eric
larson who was here to talk about his
book on the white city said about the
same thing that you do you think you're
ever going to clash he endorses your
book you're going to clash on the same
subjects no because
i know what i'm writing about and i have
some idea what eric's writing about and
i think they're you know very different
things so i think we'll be fine again
the cover of the book of empires of
light our guest has been jill jones
thank you very much for joining us thank
you so much for having me
[Music]
for a video copy call
1-877 on c-span for free transcripts or
to learn more about book notes visit us
at booknotes.org
next week on booknotes our guest is the
accuracy of new york times reporting on
wars from vietnam to iraq afterwards
every sunday at 6 p.m eastern end
pacific on book tv on c-span 2.
[Music]
jill jones newest book is empires of
light edison tesla westinghouse and the
race to electrify the world she talks
about it now at the chicago institution
in new york this is an hour
thank you can everyone hear okay
yeah
um well i'm really very honored to be
here and especially after i had a chance
to see who all the previous authors were
um this is my first time at chicago but
i feel that i'm in a long line of
very wonderful writers so i feel very
uh
humble
i was asked to talk about how i came to
write a book about this early history of
electricity
and i found that this question i was
asked everywhere i went as i was
working on this book and when i went out
to promote this book
and this suggested to me that this was
not seen as a glamorous cutting edge and
fabulous subject that it definitely is
so i'm going to just uh
talk in a very uh i guess sort of
meandering way about how i did come to
write this book and give you some sort
of idea of just the life of of the
writer it
really began with my first book which i
uh began working on in 1981 i was a
journalist in new york city
and i became extremely fascinated with
the
history or the story of the south bronx
which
was a suburb of manhattan that really
sprang up in a manner of a decade or two
in the wake of this building of the
subways
but what was really spectacular about
the south bronx is the way it went up in
flames
um
[Music]
really almost a near-death experience
arson gangs drugs
and abandonment and i think for most
americans they really became aware of
the south bronx in 1977
when president jimmy carter went to
charlotte street and it was that
televised backdrop of these half
demolished buildings and this kind of
moonscape of rubble
and this is america in the late 20th
century we're a very powerful rich
country and yet here's a part of
what's actually also the richest uh city
in the country looking like something
after world war two and the typical
comparison was the dresden i mean it was
a really a quite a spectacular
sight
um
and i should also just mention because i
just discovered this that peter davidson
who was my first editor uh was here nine
years ago at chitago as someone at this
microphone
um
so that was my first book which was
about the south bronx and i should say
that in in 2002 i had the good fortune
to do a revised
uh edition
and
the title which is south bronx rising
the rise fall and resurrection of
american city
and what most people don't know even if
they live in manhattan is that in fact
the south bronx has been almost
completely rebuilt it's really a triumph
of the
grassroots groups there who i have to
say have been become incredibly savvy
real estate
operators and
collaborating with mayor ed koch he was
really sick of being
i guess
dumped on for the whole homelessness
situation in new york and he committed
a billion dollars to the rebuilding of
the south bronx it was a very courageous
act with the near miraculous uh
outcome so it used to be if you drove
across the south bronx expressway you
used to see these empty buildings and
they had these decals on the windows
with little daisies and things to make
it look as if someone lived there now
people do really live in those buildings
when i was working on my book on the
south bronx one of the things that
really surprised me was to hear people
who had grown up there and watched with
great sorrow as their neighborhoods
began to
deteriorate and crumble around them
was the role of drugs and specifically
heroin had become really a plague and a
curse but it began in the 1950s and that
was really surprising to me because
i'm doing these interviews in the early
1980s and i thought of the drug culture
as something that really struck us in
the 1960s
and these people were talking about how
the how the drug culture of heroin
really kind of metastasized and then
began to corrode and destroy the social
fabric of the neighborhoods they lived
in and that was really how my first book
led to my second book because i could
not find a book that answered this
question of why america had seemed to
have such a powerful drug culture so
as you can imagine in the course of
working on a book like the south bronx i
read a fair number of phd
dissertations and i thought you know i
could do this and
the book that i write next i really
ought to get myself a phd in the course
of doing it
and in fact when i began to look into
the the history of drugs in in america i
found that it was
it was complicated and it was uh very
rich and i i really didn't know how to
think about it and so i had moved to
baltimore
my husband went to do his residency at
johns hopkins hospital and
i had the very good fortune to be able
to go and study with john heim a
cultural historian at hopkins and i was
that rare person i arrived knowing
exactly what i wanted to do as my
dissertation which was the history of
illegal drugs in america
i got my phd in 1992
and um
then i continued to work on an and
expand
this topic and i had again good fortune
being supported by the ford foundation
and then also the national endowment for
the humanities
and i
um
signed a book contract with scribner
which published the book in 1996. i
always wanted to call this book dope
which
you may be surprised no it actually is
the the one of the earliest historical
words referring to
drugs it was a dutch word which means
kind of a gooey black axle grease and it
was a kind of a slang for smoking opium
uh
but unfortunately my publishers didn't
like that and so my book ended up with
the completely
hard to remember hard to pronounce
titled habcats narcs and pipe dreams
though i like the subtitle a history of
america's romance with
illegal drugs so as you saw see my in my
second book really came out of my first
book
and then when i finished my second book
i was really didn't know what i was
going to do next um
at this point really for almost 15 years
i had been
immersed in what my husband calls the
bummer beat
and these are two books that looked at
really you know very large failures of
american
life and public policy
um
but one thing i did know is that when i
was writing about these books i was
really enchanted with this the decades
that i wrote about in the late 19th
century the gilded age which technically
is from about 1877 um
to world war one and one of the reasons
i think this is just such a wonderful
era and i think everyone who comes to
chicago has probably a stronger sense of
it than your average american because
you
participate
in what's really a very gilded age kind
of enterprise with all of its uh
richness and sense of history
but the gilded age is so wonderful
because it's this era when america
becomes wealthy and powerful it's a big
era of immigration
vanderbilts rockefellers goulds
andrew carnegie jp morgan and of course
edison who we've already heard from i
don't know now he's disappeared
um and westinghouse and these are all
people who who created great new
industries and made great fortunes so
it's really you know the beginning of
the united states as we know it today
the other thing that's great about the
gilded age if you're historian and
writers there's almost no rules and so
people do a lot of bad things which is
makes for good drama
at the same time there's no safety net
and that's also a great drama because
it's you just cannot
imagine from the vantage point of the
21st century that you know when you lost
a job uh
there was nothing there waiting for you
i mean just penury was
a very real prospect
the other thing that was really
interesting to me as i was contemplating
you know what what to work on next was
that in fact in the mid 1990s there were
very few new books about the gilded age
um but i did feel that after writing two
bummer beat books and being deeply
immersed in drugs and um
urban decay that i i wanted to write a
book about american success and why
america was such an amazing engine of
invention opportunity and prosperity i
grew up my my whole life overseas and so
i actually always i think tend to see
the united states more with foreign eyes
and so things that i mean it always
seemed like a very rich country to me
because i grew up in a lot of poor
countries overseas my father worked for
the agency for international development
and um
i lived in many poor places obviously in
a state of great privilege comparison to
everyone else there
the other thing about my attraction to
the gilded age was a lot of my favorite
books are from that time and um
that used this backdrop of new money and
wealth to tell some really wonderful
stories one of my all-time favorite
authors is edith wharton and i have to
say that house of mirth
the the character in that lily bart i
think is is just one of the most
compelling and poignant
depictions of an american woman trying
to make her way in a very
difficult
but wealthy newly wealthy society i also
love henry james's portrait of a lady
which is having lived overseas a lot i
guess that's something of an expatriate
i
found that fascinating and then david
mccullough who's come here quite a bit i
noticed that one of his books is that he
lectured on here is one of my other
favorite books mornings on horseback
about teddy roosevelt i also know that
teddy roosevelt one of my favorite
gilded age characters has also been here
so i felt very steeped in
one of my favorite eras
so i started looking around for a gilded
age story
i in fact i and i
even i spent a lot of time researching
five different people
um
and i actually even wrote a book
proposal it was a really bad idea i
could never figure out
how to connect these five people um one
of them was a railroad titan another
one's a tobacco titan
but it just never came together and so i
was
you know really sort of a
you know in a
state of being quite stymied when
something happened completely out of
left field and i have to say that is one
of the
delights of writing books is that
because you write these books they go
out and they kind of take on a life of
their own you never quite know
what's going to happen you know when the
phone rings these days it tends to
happen via email
but out of left field i got a phone call
from the drug enforcement administration
in washington
asking if i would come and curate a
museum in their headquarters which i
found an extremely unlikely
development because i actually had a
very acrimonious relationship with them
when i was writing my book on illegal
drugs because i wanted documents from
them uh through the freedom of
information act and which they did not
want to give me
but i guess you know bygones or bygones
so they invited me to do this excuse me
well this was an extremely interesting
experience
um
for 25 years they had been collecting
i guess you could call them drug
artifacts
ever since 1914 they have had agents all
over the world
and for 25 years
they had been collecting things from
retired agents active agents and they
literally had all this stuff
down in the basement of their
headquarters in pentagon city i mean you
went down through the garage and there
were these
basement rooms and they opened them up
and i had been spending many years in
archives and libraries and so this was i
mean it was really great fun you know
they'd open these boxes and there would
be these
incredible old chinese opium pipes
drug paraphernalia from
court cases in the 1930s
original movie posters from things like
reefer madness or i was a teenage drug
addict
and then they had just a truly
astonishing collection of everything
that had ever been used to smuggle or
attempt to smuggling drugs
shoes decks of cards giant surfboards
anyway so this was this was great fun
and it sort of gave me
something to do while i continued to
wrestle while this problem of um trying
to find a gilded age person sufficiently
interesting to carry a book and so you
will of course naturally imagine well it
was at
this time that i ran into edison and
westinghouse and got going on this book
about electricity but no i'm telling you
this is a circular story and so that's
not how i came across them
the person that i did come across was a
man named alexander kassad and i'm sure
most of you have never heard of him he
was president from 1899 to 1906 at the
pennsylvania railroad and
at that time that was the nation's most
powerful and important corporation it
would be hard to find something
comparable today because there's just so
many big powerful corporations but you
might say you would be someone like bill
gates and
microsoft um
ironically today the person who's really
famous is his sister mary cassatt the
painter and of course in in their day he
was enormously famous and no one had
ever heard of her
um and so that is an interesting uh
i guess twist of fate and fame
but
the reason that alexander cassatt was
famous in his day is that he solved a
huge problem that affects the
pennsylvania railroad for 30 years and
that was how to get into manhattan
which was in those days america's
richest and most important city and not
only was it the biggest seaport in the
united states it was the biggest seaport
in the world
and the only way you could get to
manhattan in those days on a boat if you
were coming from any place but albany
everyone just sort of always assumes
there always were tunnels and bridges
into manhattan but obviously at some
point they had to get built
and uh cassatt's great work of genius
was to conceive and see through
what was the nation's biggest civil
engineering project of
his day and that's if you have ever
taken the amtrak into new york you've
been in cassettes tunnels so they came
under the hudson river they went through
manhattan and they also on the long
island railroad they went under the east
river they built the hellsgate bridge
and then they continued on up into
new england and obviously the crown
jewel of this whole enterprise was
charles mckim's
pennsylvania station
so
alexander kassad was the person that i
found to write about you know carry a
really wonderful gilded aged book
and george westinghouse and alexander
cassatt were old professional friends
cassatt had helped westinghouse who was
the inventor of the air brick perfect
his product and then get it
used and made standard for the whole
pennsylvania railroad line and then for
almost every other railroad in the
country
thus
catapulting westinghouse into the top
ranks of pittsburgh industrialists
and so in search of cassot material i
read the two existing westinghouse
biographies
um now i now have to make yet another
kind of homage to
a book that
was an influence on me and that was
about the time that i'm reading these
westinghouse biographies
i'm also reading simon winchester's the
professor and the madman
i really love this book i had read many
years earlier caught in the web of words
which was also about the oxford english
dictionary
and i loved winchester's book with its
slice of history
and i thought i would love to write a
book like this because you have to
remember these two earlier books i wrote
each of them covered more than a century
of
history and with each advancing decade
you had a new cast of characters so i'd
never had
the chance to write a book just where
you had a few people and you stuck with
them through the whole book so i thought
that would be
a really
uh you know a treat
so i'm reading along in henry proud's
biography of
westinghouse when i encounter these
chapters
about the war of the electric current
and i have to say they just stopped me
dead in my tracks because i thought i
knew something about thomas edison but
what i did not know is that he had
helped develop and promote the first use
of the electric chair
and i thought hmm
now this is not the thomas edison that i
know the
folksy beloved kindly genius inventor
this is a very ruthless businessman
who's
prepared to see
a criminal die so that he can smear his
biggest competitor
and
the war of the electric currents in
which uh edison is and his system of dc
are pitted against tesla and
westinghouse and their rival system of
alternating current is actually a very
well known episode in science but it was
not a well-known episode to me because
i'm not very well educated in science
um so in the summer of
2000 my daughter went to suzuki camp for
five days
and i took with me five books uh john
o'neill's biography of nikola tesla
these two westinghouse biographies which
i've mentioned and then two edison
biographies one by matthew joseph and
josephson who we know is the author of
the robber barons
and then also a book by paul israel on
it called
inventing the century which is a
wonderful biography of medicine and i
spent that whole week just reading these
books and by the end of the week i had
my outline and i was really hooked on
this story and i was very excited
now i should mention that i did not know
a single thing about electricity or how
it worked
and that my husband the scientist
thought this was hilarious
that i whose
he knew he is a scientist i should say
um and with this total intuitive
understanding of electricity that i
found extremely galling and was deeply
jealous of him
um that i who was a general ignoramus on
the subject of science but
and electricity in particular that i was
going to write a book about the early
history and development of electricity
as a commercial entity
so now the other thing you might wonder
is now what about alexander cassatt i
mean why am i just
you know dumping him and i actually had
at this i was that far on that book that
had actually written a book proposal you
know rough draft
well the thing i knew was that to write
this cassatt book i was going to make
many many forays to the pennsylvania
railroad archives which
became available probably about
10 years ago so you know say four years
ago when our three years ago when i was
working on all this they'd only been
available for about five years they're
up in the the state archives in
harrisburg pennsylvania i live in
baltimore so it's a 90-minute drive it's
very doable
the thing i knew because i had worked in
these archives they're incredibly
labyrinthine
they are extremely complicated no one up
there really understands them
and they i finally discovered the reason
they've never bothered to master them is
they don't actually really own them and
in theory at any moment the archives
could be removed they belong to some
legal entity that's left over from the
demise of
the pennsylvania railroad in the new
york central
so i thought it was probably fairly
unlikely that anyone else was going to
make as many trips up to pennsylvania as
would be required because when they
would go the first few times they would
get very discouraged about ever trying
to extricate anything from these
archives
um
the war of the electric currents as a
subject on the other hand something
anyone could do from their house and the
reason was that the edison archives had
gone online this is an um i mean the
internet is an amazing
uh
it is an amazing tool
and the edison archive is a searchable
database
that has about a half million documents
in it
it is also not that easy to use but paul
israel who is the
managing editor there is a lovely fellow
and i spent a fair amount of time on the
telephone with him staring at my screen
saying well now i don't understand you
know if i click this why isn't this
happening and he guided me through them
and helped me find many things
nikola tesla basically what there are is
there a few letters in in the library of
congress and otherwise
he tesla wrote a great deal about
himself he's has a wonderful voice he's
a very peculiar man and he wanted to
preserve his own legacy so he made sure
that he wrote a great deal about himself
and again because of the internet and on
a site called the american book exchange
which is where
some significant percentage of the used
bookstores in this country are
on that site
almost anything that tesla ever wrote
you will be able to find that way
um westinghouse was actually a much more
complicated issue um which i'll talk a
little bit about more later
so to write this book you know you
didn't need to leave your house too much
except you know you'd want to go to new
york and i certainly went to buffalo
niagara falls in pittsburgh that's not
the same as having to go week after week
or month after month up to harrisburg so
i thought i was probably pretty safe in
putting alexander cassatt aside and
dedicating myself to uh
edison tesla and westinghouse now let me
just since i'm here in upstate new york
let me say something a little bit about
my research trip up to buffalo
also kind of unforgettable
event
i had this romantic idea that i would
take the train to experience what all
those gilded age millionaires and robber
barons did when they would go upstate to
see what had happened
uh with their with their investments
into the niagara power hydroelectric
plant that was being built there
but i have to say
somehow when you're on a shabby amtrak
car it doesn't really feel like jp
morgan heading up in his luxurious
private pullman but
you know i
i decided it was worth a try
but i i consoled myself by re-reading
lauren belford's city of light and i
know that she was here
this was a very influential book for me
when i was trying to figure out whether
to do this project or night not
first of all i mean it's
her story is set against what is
actually the third battleground of the
world the electric currents which is the
hydroelectric plant up at niagara falls
but
but beyond everything i love the tone
and atmosphere of her gilded age i
thought she really
got it right so as i'm on this train
trying to pretend i'm in jp morgan's
private pullman
um i'm rereading city of light to get in
the right frame of mind
i get into buffalo it's in the winter so
it's you know you arrive in the evening
and it's dark already
go to my hotel which was downtown
i ate and went to bed because i had a
big busy and you know big day the next
day
about two o'clock in the morning i was
woken up
it was just the most ferocious
thunder and lightning storm i have ever
seen in my life and this hotel room had
very large picture windows and i was
pretty high up like on this eighth floor
or something
and i got up and looked out and these
gilded age buildings that were
below me i mean just all this thunder
and lightning is crashing down
well i decided that this was nikola
tesla
expressing himself
because he loved lightning i mean you
know lightning to him was the expression
of electricity
and buffalo was the city of his greatest
triumph which was
the
uh development of alternating current
and its transmission from this
hydroelectric plant
uh into the city of buffalo and what i
didn't know as i was watching this
amazing display and you know telling
myself oh it's nichole tesla
that in fact the very
building where this wonderful electrical
soiree and banquet was held fedding him
right after the first transmission of of
electrical power was in the ellicott
building and i did not know that that
building not only was it still around
but it was
really like just blocks from where i was
staying and i found out the next morning
so i just
you know was very thrilled i rushed
right down there and it
i mean it was obviously not in the state
it wasn't its glory days but it had been
refurbished and everything that i had
read about this building that was
magnificent about it was still there
it's a building that was
designed by daniel
hudson-burnham who was the creator of
the world's fair the white city of 1893
and a very famous chicago architect this
had been the largest office building in
the world in 1896 was its claim to fame
and it had an incredible interior
courtyard which you can still see of
this beautiful stained glass ceiling
and then these really incredible
elevators with these bar relief bronze
doors with all kinds of scenes from you
know sort of frontier
niagara and
new york
so that was that was just really a
thrill to you know see these actual
places and feel that nicola tesla had
been
present
um
now when you actually go to niagara
falls of course
stanford white's cathedral of power
which
housed
these original hydroelect plant is gone
and all that's left oddly is this little
building which is a miniature of that
which was a transformer building and i
you know some dreamer
has bought this building and warehoused
it with this vision of someday opening a
museum in it i don't know exactly what
the status of that is but i suspect it's
still sitting there waiting for the
return of glory
and then of course there's always the
big statue at niagara falls of nekla
tesla which is fun
but what i mainly remember is going to
the niagara falls public library which
has a very good local history section
and there were some very
wonderful and unique tesla items
but mainly the librarian bitterly
telling me
if he had not come if he had not
invented electricity new york state
would still be
the really important place it had been
because everyone wouldn't have gone
south to the sun belt because there
wouldn't be air conditioning
[Laughter]
i thought okay
um
so as i was right working one of the
reasons i was so attracted to the gilded
age i think you know as as the 1990s
progress
it was really an era that
resonated to our own times i mean
both these eras there was just uh
extraordinary technological advances
um that really spurred big revolutions
in the way people live and work i mean
obviously electricity is a much bigger
revolution than the internet but the
internet is a big revolution
and the other thing was
really a great challenge as a writer and
that was to try and write a book
where
you took something that everyone
doesn't give a second thought to
electricity and try and take them back
to a time when this was really exotic
when it was very expensive
when it was something that was a great
luxury so that was a you know very
enjoyable to me as a historian to try
and kind of
recreate
that age
it was a joy to spend two years with
these three men i mean they were really
extraordinary and to me each of them was
so
american and very unique and brilliant
in their own way so edison at this time
he's already the world's greatest
inventor ultimately ended up with 1093
patents which remains the most patents
that any american has so he's still like
the champion
of the patent office
he's a completely self-made
wonderfully folksy he was the beloved in
the newspapers he just
um had a tremendous way with words
he started his life as a news boy he was
trained himself to be a crack
telegrapher and from there really
created himself as as an inventor he had
an amazing sense of pr and he was such
an optimist one of my favorite essen
lines is later in life his whole lab
burned down out in orange park
in orange new jersey and this is his
quote oh shucks it's all right we've
just got rid of a lot of old rubbish
i mean you have to really love someone
like that
he also
was incredibly important in the sense of
bringing about this marriage between
science and corporate america
one of the reasons edison prevailed over
all of his competitors is he had the
money and he had the money because wall
street backed him
um the other thing that was very fun
about this book was seeing edison really
at his
darkest and his most most ruthless i
mean that's not the way we think of him
and so i call this edison for grown-ups
um
and then there's nikola tesla
who most of us have never heard of i
knew him
because i'd had a student in a writing
class who wrote a paper about him
because there's a band called tesla
and so i knew a little something about
him he was amazingly hot very highly
educated in contrast to either edison or
westinghouse
he was an edison employee who
tried to get edison to adopt ac edison
was so proud of his
brilliance
in developing this entire system of
lighting he could not bring himself to
admit that someone had a better system
tesla was just this fabulous eccentric
um couldn't be a bear to be in a room
with a woman wearing pearls
he liked everything divisible by three
so when he would swim laps he would
never swim 26 laps he would swim 27 laps
if he stayed in a hotel or lived in an
apartment
the room number had to be divisible by
three
he had a great phobia of germs he died
almost any given night that he was in
new york and either delmonicus or walt
the waldorf and he would have a big pile
of pristine napkins and he would take
one and use each one to
clean off his knives forks
and
plates and glasses and what have you
he was incredibly ahead of his time in
terms of his inventions
um
and in the end of all of his many
inventions i mean he was really a
visionary
only ac was either fully developed
and one of the other things about
nicholas tesla that's really charming is
he has a big cult following but they do
things like talk about how he probably
was a space alien because he was so far
ahead of his time that's the only
explanation you know that you could have
um
and then finally there's george
westinghouse who i have to say was the
one i liked best of all these three
which maybe is not the right thing to
say here in chicago in the home of
edison
i knew nothing about westinghouse i just
thought of him as a brand name on
refrigerators and air con air
conditioners but he was really this very
charismatic and
reckless entrepreneur
and in an era of robber barons he had a
tremendous concern for his own
workers which was very touching um
and he was only really cared about
having cutting-edge products you know if
his product wasn't as good as it should
be he would throw it all out and just
move on to the next thing
um
and one my favorite of his
sayings was impossible is not a word in
my vocabulary so he would go out and
commit himself to doing things come back
to pittsburgh and his workers
were just appalled and yet they were so
inspired by him and loved to work with
him that somehow or another they would
come up with the solutions
the the interesting thing about
westinghouse is ultimately i think he
represents much more than edison modern
corporate science and the reason is very
straightforward he was very willing to
collaborate with other people and
recognize that other people's inventions
or ideas were better than his so as with
when he saw that tesla has had invented
you know a really wonderful system at
basie and had figured out how to use
alternating current in a motor
um he bought all his patents hired him
as a consultant and between the two of
them they
figured out the system of electricity
that is the basis of electricity to this
day all over the world which is pretty
amazing a technological
advance that has lasted for a century
um
the other thing i love about
westinghouse he was very dedicated to
his wife tesla's biggest love was a
white pigeon
edison i think you could safely say was
fairly chronically neglectful
but westinghouse set up both
telegraph and telephone so that no
matter where he was in the world and he
traveled a great deal he could always
call his wife every day and i think
those of us who are married have to
think that that's a nice thing
so i was very sad when i finished this
book because i knew that was the end of
my days
i suppose i should say nights with the
edison tesla and westinghouse
and
as you can imagine i'm now back spending
my days with alexander cassad
and
the title of this book the working title
is conquering gotham and this is also
you know not like another book of gilded
age titans in technology
um which i'm enjoying a great deal
but i think you know i think i think
there's always going to be very deep
spot in my heart for empires of light so
that's the back story vampire's delight
i'd be happy to take any questions
and thank you so much for having me to
talk with just been a delight
was very excited when i
saw that you were going to come i'm from
sharon pennsylvania which is a
my uh binary pathway here and it's home
to
the largest western house transformer
plant
up about another 20 years
because my father would have been in
your book he was someone that changed
high voltage
down to transformers
and westinghouse put him through college
and returned for five years of working
for them which turned out beautifully
because it was 1930 and everybody else
in the experimental area was let go
except my father and his partner
two quick stories he said he had a model
t
on a
football field
and they shot the model t with high
boulders expecting to catch fire explode
nothing happened so they had to keep on
doing that the other thing
he was on the ladder in another one of
his experiments he had his partner down
with the switch to turn on the
electricity
someone came through the door and said
hi
the guy turned on the electricity a
father was on the floor next to her fear
he survived but that's her good
i brought with me a 1927
westinghouse book
that has blue linen
reports on it and i would like to you
know take her over there so if you could
see it or stay here and now my question
what am i supposed to do with this
the westinghouse museum
it's in
wilmerding and um on the internet just
put in george westinghouse museum and
they'll come up and they're really a
repository for what's left i it's very
astonishing to me to discover when i
began to research this that the
westinghouse corporation didn't exist
anymore that it was uh dismantled in
1996 in the way so many
companies were but this is a museum
that's run by volunteers and um they're
very dedicated and actually what i was
going to say is that i was
in a state of all near panic as i was
finishing you know towards the end of
writing this book because it was just so
hard to find anything
about westinghouse he was not a man who
left any papers no letters i found more
westinghouse letters in the edison
archive than i did anywhere else
you know between the two of them and
their companies
and in the end i when i was really
finished everything else i i went to
wilmer ding to use this archive and the
people who run it really have almost no
idea what's in it
and um but they were very kind and
generous and they just opened this huge
vault and they said well you know
whatever you want to look at and then
they just left me by myself and gave me
well i had my daughter with me as my
xeroxing expert
um
and
you know whatever i wanted to xerox that
would be fine
and i
had this really really rare experience a
historian which is lo and behold there
was
something no one knew existed which was
a huge oral history project which was
done by the company in the 1930s where
they interviewed every person who'd ever
had anything to do with western house
who was still alive and this really
saved me
because from that there were first-hand
reports from reginald belfield who was
you know the original
helped design
test
and develop the
first original transformer with george
westinghouse so this was just historical
gold i mean one thing after another on
those lines
and i came home and thought oh my god
you know i finally
and these you know this quote impossible
is not in my vocabulary before i found
this i did not know if george
westinghouse himself had actually ever
been to the chicago world's fair to see
his own
incredible achievement because in all
the coverage of the world's fair there's
never any mention of him
once the fair opens and it was only
through the interviews with the man who
managed their world's fair that i found
out that he did eventually go
um in the middle of the fair with his
wife but all he was really interested in
was looking at everything electrical he
never went to anything ceremonial wasn't
interested in getting any kind of a
claim um
never gave almost a public speech in his
whole life until
he lost his electrical company to
wall street predators and so in
his he died in 1914 many people said of
a broken heart from losing his
electrical company
um
in the progressive era he became kind of
a crusader
for government regulation of wall street
because he felt as if his company was
stolen from him
i forgot to mention that
mentioning general electric was worse
[Applause]
you know that that was the other um i
don't know how are we doing for time
here where oh okay excuse me
my husband read your book and of course
well actually eric larson is a friend of
mine because he used to live in
baltimore
and we were writing our books at the
same time though and i really
loved reading his book because
i only could devote a certain amount of
time to researching the world's fair
whereas he devoted great amount of time
and so i really just enjoyed reading the
full story
of daniel hudson-burnham and the whole
tale of the fair and we were also
reading at the same time these chicago
papers
about the fair
and
um
one of the
real pleasures of working in the gilded
age is it was an era when the only way
people learn things was from newspapers
and so the papers went into a level of
detail about everything
that you can't imagine today because
they had to tell you what people looked
like what they wore what the weather
felt like so much of this
comes through to you now through
television or on radio or whatever
reporters don't feel obliged to
tell you these things anymore and
newspapers had very distinctive
personalities i mean they
some new newspapers were very republican
some were very democratic some
uh you know were very focused on scandal
so
you know reading the different papers
and so the world's fair coverage of the
chicago papers was was quite
different and actually the um
the best paper was the chicago ocean
record i mean
chicago ocean
don't know where that that newspaper
title came from but so
uh eric and i had many enjoyable chats
about that and um
it was just you know great fun
yes
if you are looking for another project
given given your love of westinghouse
what a great company you built
as late as approximately 1970 when jack
welch took over general electric those
two companies were about on par
and yet we know what happened
westinghouse went on there was broken
[Music]
so you might want to give a thought to
maybe a comparative what happened
between those two companies
and one blossom
two reasons of history for me i like to
live in longer ago than that
so going back and forth i guess okay i
was wondering
i hadn't read your book and i haven't
read the other book either so this
question will be
asking totally
comment
um
the
thoughts of these people on the adherent
right of the public to access to
electricity
and so
uh
argument was there a discussion was
there any kind of words between them
i don't think the issue of public access
came about until electricity was really
commonplace actually one of the things
that was really surprising to me i i i
believe the figure is that in 1908 only
eight percent of american houses had
electricity
so it was a pretty slow process
um
the places that got electricity equipped
most quickly were obviously commercial
enterprises and then after that came
households
and the the issue of the right to
electricity
really came to a head i think
in the in an issue of rural
electrification
because the question was you know who
was going to spend vast sums of money to
give electricity to people where it
wasn't really economic
and um i don't i have to say i don't
feel really very well informed in that
but having just happened to look in some
electric journals for
different kinds of things i do
remember seeing in the 30s when this was
a really hot issue with fdr and he
really rammed it through
some very bitter ads in these journals
run by electric utilities
basically
denouncing the idea that
the government was invading what they
saw as their turf and
uh going into the generation of
electricity and this was socialism and
so forth but i don't think it
i don't think it became an issue until
electricity was
commonplace enough in in the probably
the majority of american homes
that the feeling arose that really it
was
it would should be something that
everyone was entitled to
so that's the best answer i can give you
on that
yeah thank you for your lecture today
it's been wonderful but in the uh book
review we had last week on the book it
has brought out that tesla at one point
when they were
when western house was having some
financial difficulties
but tesla just tore up his contract said
i will work together on this and
consequently he
never did enjoy the
financial rewards in the future
that uh
and westinghouse
given westinghouse
character how do you explain that
did he
make it right for tesla did he help him
no i mean you know this is actually
the one to me the one unanswered
question or the you know the mystery as
i said by and large westinghouse was an
extraordinarily decent man i mean to
this day in pittsburgh i think you got a
sense of this with the
woman who spoke first
he's really kind of a revered
character and his company is still
really
respected and there's a great sort of
mourning that a company that cares so
much about its employees is you know
gone
but it's very clear no it he never made
that good i don't know why um
later in life
i mean when westinghouse was long gone
he died in 1914 and tesla lived on until
1946.
the company became so embarrassed by
tesla's penury that they gave him
what i think you have to say is a quite
a
niggling
pension of sort which is they paid his
rent at the new yorker hotel
now in contrast ge
for whom william stanley worked when he
was on hard times gave him a pension of
a thousand dollars a month which must
have been a lot of money you know in the
20s and 30s
so that was an injustice tesla had he
gotten his royalties
it was um calculated he would have made
17 million dollars
so he gave up a vast fortune
it's a it's a very um
kind of ugly
part of the story and for which i i
don't that's one of the things you know
you think oh you'll get an answer to
this
one
that's one of the frustrations about
being a historian you have lots of
questions and
many of them just never do get answered
and that was one that never got answered
from me
okay there's no one okay
first of all i'm an electrical engineer
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
edison was no dumb he realized that the
ac current had one great big advantage
and that was
large
transmission
of power at very high voltage of a long
distance
uh stanley was arguably also the
inventor of the transformer
uh
although
the point was available
so
uh edison
bought out the stanley works or making
transformers located in pittsfield
massachusetts
and they also use pcbs for coolant those
transformers and the housatonic river in
pittsfield
at the same time edison
without a mathematician himself
hired
charles proteus assignments
now at the time there were many
mysterious things that went on the
alternating car which did not happen
with direct car
stein then sat down and
what edison by this time was they
acknowledged the fact that uh ac did
have some uses
and steinmetz worked out a lot of the
mathematical
systems that is electrical engineers we
now use just at
high school or count relationship
uh
i worked in the locomotive department in
here in pennsylvania
and
we built locomotives with pennsylvania
railroad i never met i said
[Music]
so in erie pennsylvania
the local artist department there are
also
records of historically and a lot of
them have to do with cooperation right
ourselves
[Applause]
i had just uh two quick questions the
first was both about tesla the person
was about his financial regulation but
at the moment
and he gave a really good answer
um
i read prodigal genius and to listen to
the story of tesla he was
the ultimate scientist all right
governors were
and since he had discovered ways to
transfer electricity halfway around
record keeping he did or are there any
files or memoirs he had because
some stories tell that well the power
distribution companies didn't want any
of that to ever be filming them to
anybody for as long as
what
i know about
tesla is that he you know built this
very mysterious tower
energy
tower or something like that and he went
to jp morgan
telling him that this was a going to be
a radio he was working on radio and this
was a broadcasting
now jp morgan had a lot
and you know various investors
affiliated with him had a lot of money
wrapped up in the standard um you know
electrical developments and because he
was one of edison's earliest backers
and as soon as marconi transmitted
across
the ocean i mean at that point then uh
jp morgan lost all interest well then
tesla confesses well this is not really
just about radio it's really about
energy transmission
but
you know tesla had a very bad track
record as someone who saw his inventions
through he was a visionary in the sense
he was really interested in the larger
cosmic questions having to do with
electricity electricity was his passion
and understanding electricity was his
passion and he wasn't
really in his heart of hearts interested
for instance in making a better light
bulb very early on he had invented what
was a proto-fluorescent
light
and
so for instance
john
jacob astor i don't know the fourth or
third
gave him you know a reasonable size
amount of money to develop this light
and
tesla took that money went to colorado
springs and did a lot of cosmic
visionary
electrical investigations and then
returned to new york with no further
progress on the proto-fluorescent light
and so
you know astor just washed his hands of
him though he did let him continue to
live in his hotel and never pay any rent
until they finally
evicted him
took the mortgage on the warden cliff
tower and then
uh blew up the warden cliff tower so the
land would be worth something
i mean tassel's life is a drama
such as you can only hope for as a
writer
um i just after i sent in my manuscript
to my agent
he sent me back this email and he said
this man is an author's dream
[Laughter]
but it's it's heartbreaking i mean it's
a heartbreaking story and really to this
day no one quite knows with tesla
how much of this
stuff that he
invented really could have ever been
made real but i
one thing you have to know is he died in
the middle of world war ii
and the us government immediately
confiscated
most of his files
and so you wonder you know where are his
files i don't think really people know
and then so you know this all really
feeds into you know these kind of
conspiracy theories and um
part of this was because
tesla was saying that he had invented a
death ray and this would solve the
problem for
world peace and you know we would have
the death ray and people would have to
respect us and
so
and tesla's just a mysterious character
that
it's hard to have definitive knowledge
of
what he really did and didn't know but i
mean just imagine this it's 1890 and
nikola tesla
has invented remote control he
he held a demonstration it was in
madison square garden the old one he
made a big huge pond and on it he put a
giant boat
and he stood back and he just made this
boat move around wherever he wanted the
lights flashed on and off
no and people thought it was magic and
he didn't mind let it having people
think it was magic he liked to be called
a wizard
now if thomas edison had invented remote
control you would have had the remote
control you know carriage door that went
up and down or
something he would have done something
with it but see tesla was really kind of
um
happy to amaze people with it and then
go back to his lab and continue on
he was actually way ahead of marconi on
on the writ on radio
but uh his lap burned down just as he
was about to you know really step
forward
and ultimately marconi got
after tesla was dead marconi got into a
fight
with the u.s government over his patents
the government wanted to develop radio
for some war application and he took the
government to court and
and he lost the supreme court said no
the original patents belonged to tesla
well tesla was dead so that didn't do
him much good but you know it gives you
an idea and tesla's problem well one of
the the other
discoveries for me are revelations about
working on this book was the
litigiousness
of these men edison
really had a huge leg up because he had
a lot of lawyers and boy he went after
people and westinghouse was the same and
in fact actually one of the reasons that
ge and westinghouse began to cooperate
was essentially because it cost them so
much money their legal fees were so
gigantic they just simply had to come to
terms on patent sharing
um
but that is what tesla did not have he
did not have lawyers and for that reason
um people just felt free to infringe on
his inventions and patents and
he uh was very uh poverty stricken for
that reason
one last question
okay can you tell us something about
edison in chicago how much had he spent
here i heard that he
installed the electricity in the
automatic hotel it was the first hotel
in the united states to enjoy electric
power
you know
i i don't no i don't unfortunately i
don't know any talk with stories in fact
it turned out i always been pronouncing
his wife's name wrong i thought her name
was mina miller but it's
minor
so no i don't know anything about edison
except
he's looking at us some from some place
here on his banner
thank you very much
jill jones other books include south
bronx rising and hep cats narcs and pipe
dreams
empires of light is published by
programs anytime visit our website
history
you're watching american history tv
all weekend every weekend on c-span 3
all weekend american history tv is
joining our comcast cable partners to
showcase the history of colorado springs
colorado to learn more about the cities
on our 2014 tour visit cspan.org
local content
and we continue now with our look at the
history of colorado springs this is
american history tv on c-span 3.
nikola tesla became fascinated with this
new
um
creation going on in the world of
electricity
when he came to this country he started
working right away with thomas edison
but
there was some conflict there because
what the what developed is what's
referred to as the current wars
because
edison was very committed to using
direct current
and tesla
understood that alternating current was
more
it was more economical
and more effective and could be
transferred over great distances at a
far far less cost
but tesla is interested in a lot of
other
areas of physics
and electricity
and eventually
he comes to colorado in 1899.
well this exhibition really sort of
explores some of the ideas that tesla
was exploring during his career
through some historical information and
reproduction of photographs and then
also
through artist projects that maybe mine
some of the same
scientific or creative territory
that's one of the things that we found
really interesting to explore with the
exhibition is sort of the overlaps and
artistic process and creative and
scientific process and sort of trying to
explore the creative aspects of science
um
now there is sort of this
misconception
that science is totally straightforward
that uh there is
that the the process of trial and error
doesn't involve uh
qualities like intuition or creativity
and i think that's really sort of proven
untrue
that there is this very creative sort of
intuitive piece to science and we wanted
to sort of make that a little more
transparent thinking about tesla in his
process and uh where how his ideas
seem to come in some cases from nowhere
where it
the the trajectory from where he started
to where he ended up seems a little
unclear and
i wanted to sort of look at that that
process which is what does that mean
uh for a scientist to sort of make
intuitive leaps or seemingly intuitive
leaves
this piece is by artist dove bradshaw in
collaboration with an engineer robert
bishop
and it's called tesla radio rock
it's part of an ongoing series of
bradshaws where she explores the
resonant capacities of rocks to transmit
radio signal
and one of the things that tesla was
exploring when he was here in colorado
springs was he was trying to understand
whether the earth had enough resonant
capacity that you could transmit
electricity
and radio signals directly through the
earth to get a transmission you know to
the other side of the globe
instantaneously of radio or of power and
that was one of the things that he was
exploring here and um
he left colorado springs thinking that
this was a possibility because he did
find some resonant capacity of the earth
unfortunately it's not resonant enough
to do what he had hoped it would do
and then the intergalactic signals
reference
a phenomenon that he experienced when he
was here
he heard some very uh
mathematically precise and repeated
radio bursts when he was listening with
his his large receivers
and felt that
the only conclusion that he could come
to was that it was originating from mars
and that it was a sign of intelligent
life because of its mathematical
regularity
and scientists later on came back and
replicated the experiments that he was
doing and found that what he was
listening to was radio bursts from
jupiter's moon io
which comes
in these very regular mathematically
predictable bursts
so
we can hear that
space noise transmitted through the rock
in this piece
tesla had been friend he was friends
rather with a man named leonard curtis
and he knew some of the experiments that
tesla wanted to conduct
so he invited him to come here and he
you know he said if you want to test the
upper atmosphere in new york you're
basically you're at sea level or 10 feet
above sea level
but he said if you come here you're at 6
000 feet so that made a lot of sense to
tesla
so he arrived here
on may 17
of 1899
and
was here then for the next seven months
well the first thing that when he
arrives here
is
he works out with
leonard curtis the agreement that he
would have some space to build a
laboratory
and also that
curtis was on the board
of the power company in colorado springs
so curtis provided him all the
electricity he needed in his lab
he was interested in testing out his
theories on
wireless telegraphy
mainly being able to send messages or
photographs or music
without using wires
we have to understand the context of
that time that if you wanted to
send a message to someone in another
city there had to be a wire and so you
either use a telephone or a telegraph
but by that point tesla understood
scientifically that we could send things
without using wires but he wanted to
test out his theories
his phrase when he gave his first talk
here was that he wanted to send a
message from pike speak to paris
and he knew
that he could
use wireless
a wireless method
to
in distances of say 50 feet he had done
that on little boats in a pool
and with electronics being able to
control those but he needed to have a
transmitter that was
had far more power
and that's one of the things he did at
his laboratory
is develop this
transmitter
that
created
10 million volts
in order to send
messages or whatever
long distances
and he also had to develop
receivers
that would
that would connect
properly with that transmitter
so
the big
the pictures that we've seen of him at
his laboratory is which was
about 222 feet tall
and
he
tested out this what we know as a tesla
coil basically by having lightning go
off in the room
because the tesla coil takes current
that we get normally
and
increases the frequency to a point where
it is an enormous amount of voltage
the the great story or one of the
popular stories that came out of his
experiments here was that
he and assistant were working one night
and testing this for the first time
and
he told the assistant to throw the
switch
and all of a sudden there was
electricity filling his lab
it was creating thunder it went out the
top
and then in about
five or six seconds it went off
and tesla said
asked his assistant why did you shut
that off
and
he said i didn't
but what had happened is he blew out the
power plant in town
but most
on terms of the practical things that
came out of his work here
he certainly laid the basis for x-rays
for fluorescent lights
and a number of the things that we have
today and
he was one of a number of scientists at
that time that that made a major
contribution to the technological age we
have today
throughout the weekend american history
tv is featuring colorado springs
colorado our city's tour staff recently
traveled there to learn about its rich
history
learn more about colorado springs and
other stops on c-span city's tour at
c-span.org local content
you're watching america our facebook
page
slash book tv
welcome everyone welcome good evening
my name is meredith gertler stern school
of business alum and a member of the
stern alumni council i received my mba
in 2004.
i'm thrilled to be here with you tonight
for an incredibly exciting program
it's great to see so many alumni here
joining us for this talk and i'd also
like to thank those who are watching our
feed via youtube um it's my pleasure to
introduce melissa schilling
author of the recent book quirky the
remarkable story of the traits voibles
and genius of breakthrough innovators
who changed the world in conversation
this evening with justin fox columnist
at bloomberg view
professor schilling joined stern in 2001
and is currently the herzog family
professor of management her primary
areas of research include innovation in
strategy and high technology industries
such as smartphones video games and
renewable energies she is particularly
interested in platform dynamics networks
creativity and breakthrough innovation
which you won't find surprising based on
the title of her new book our moderator
this evening is justin fox columnist for
bloomberg view writing about business he
started there in january of 2015 after
serving as editorial director and
executive editor of the harvard business
review
thank you both for being here this
evening
quirky was published by public affairs
just last month and is already a
favorite amongst academics and industry
experts alike the book suggests that
intellect alone does not create a
breakthrough innovator it is one's
personal social and emotional quirkiness
that enables true genius to break
through not just once but again and
again
after the talk we hope that you will
join us as we continue the conversation
during a reception and book signing
right here in this room
royalties from all books sold tonight
will go to stemkidsnyc
an education company that provides a
year-round intensive suite of stem
education programs for k-12 scholars and
now please allow me to hand the stage
over to melissa and justin thanks you
thank you
[Applause]
so
we're going to talk about what's inside
this book in a minute but i wanted to
ask you melissa first of all
how
it came to be and i to start that i mean
we heard the description there but what
do you do for a living what do you spend
your time doing most of the time so i'm
mostly a researcher and a teacher yeah
and the research it's about innovation
strategy
yeah so most of my research is
large-scale empirical research that's
kind of what i
would say i'm more known for so big
patent data sets alliance networks but
i've also done a fair amount on
creativity and learning
and the way
sort of the path to this book from that
i mean clearly innovation is an issue
here
there's also a paper you did um with
william belmont and ed wolfe a few years
ago that
will describe it what was the what was
the goal with that yeah okay so when i
was working by the way will baumel's
famous famous economist who was uh here
at nyu until just a couple of years ago
uh we wanted to study what made people
either entrepreneurs or inventors and he
had a hypothesis about education
and also about childhood tragedy and i
had we had some disagreements over lunch
frequently so we decided to do a really
large scale project looking at inventors
and entrepreneurs we collected about 600
on a list this was historical or yeah
historical going back to
i want to say maybe going back 200 years
and we hired a team of students to
collect biographical data on these
people and the challenge is that when
you collect data on 600 people what you
get is data that's relatively thin you
don't get a lot of details consistently
across all those people so when we came
away from that project we had some
information about their work histories
and about their education but i felt
really unsatisfied i felt like we didn't
really have
uh a lot of deep insights into what had
made these people entrepreneurs or
inventors
but but then something well before we go
on the next step who was right you were
belmont i mean what were the hypotheses
and what how did it turn out well okay
so inventors and what their educations
uh i can't remember which side he took
and i took at the time
uh but we did find that inventors on the
whole had more education than
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs on the whole
did not have advanced degrees and
inventors often did not always but it's
been changing over time or
we do uh
yeah definitely definitely the presence
of higher education has just gotten
bigger over time but for everybody not
just for inventors okay
sorry back to this book okay no so i
have to say that what really triggered
this book uh was in 2010 i was teaching
innovation strategy which i teach a lot
of courses in strategy and innovation
strategy and i do i have a textbook in
innovation so i'm always revising and
reading and staying up on the literature
and innovation and in 2010 when steve
jobs was looking very very thin
students started asking me what's going
to happen how much of that magic is in
the man himself how much of it is
actually just a myth and it's really at
apple it's is that innovation capacity
embedded in the organization structure
and the routines of apple
or or was it really him will we lose it
is there a successor can it be handed
down and then fundamentally what people
wanted to know was can i do it how can i
have that innovative capacity
and i went to the research thinking well
surely someone has answered this
question and i looked at all the
research on creative genius and
psychology i looked at all the research
on innovation and management and
it really had not been answered there's
really not that much research on this
topic and in part it's because it's a
hard question to go after in a rigorous
way so you it as i discovered with will
obama it's very hard to put together a
large sample of people and to think
you're going to get serial breakthrough
innovators in there you also can't get
them into the laboratory right if you
had called steve jobs or elon musk
they're not going to come down into the
laboratory and let you study them so the
methods that we had been trained to use
to study people just were not really
well suited to studying outliers and
these people are fundamentally outliers
or they're on serial breakthrough
innovators are rare in our history right
and to study them is is challenging so i
uh i decided to just study steve jobs
not because i thought i could publish it
but just because i needed to know at
this point i got curious and i wanted to
know something about him and i had
already taught the apple case for years
so i knew plenty about apple but this
time i wanted to know about steve as a
person so i read everything that i could
find written on him i watched all the
videos read every recorded transcript
just
studied his childhood his friends quotes
from his girlfriends quotes from his
family
and a really odd thing happened during
that time is that i started to notice
that he had some very unusual
commonalities with another innovator
that i had studied before i'd written a
case about dean caiman a few years
before that time and dean cayman you
know dean cayman for having invented the
segway personal transporter
but the segway is actually not his most
important innovation he's sort of his
biggest flop his biggest flop and it
really bothers him that it's the thing
that people know him for right but his
biggest innovation was the portable drug
infusion pump which of course completely
revolutionized care for diabetes and
also the portable dialysis machine and
prosthetic arms and i bought mobility
wheelchair so uh
that's cool i didn't even because my
nephew has one of those i did not that's
a thing came in you'll have to write him
a thank you note and uh so anyway dean
came in and steve jobs had some really
strange commonalities that at first i
couldn't understand how they could
possibly be connected to innovation
and then it hit me i'm gonna do a
multiple case study research project i'm
gonna study
eight serial breakthrough innovators i'm
gonna set up a rigorous process for
selecting them to keep myself
out of that process so that there's not
research or bias
and i didn't even care if it turned into
something i could publish i knew it was
a high risk project i could find nothing
useful or i could end up not being able
to publish it because it's all uh
qualitative and the control group is the
rest of us
uh but i did it because it was
pure fun
and um it was so fun and so illuminating
in the end i learned so much and it
turned out not just about
managing innovators or selecting
innovators and employees but also about
parenting like you learn a lot about
kids
studying these people well so what you
did then is sort of the same thing you
did with jobs but for all of these
people you've got every biography you
could find yes and
i mean i guess they're not a lot of
videos of marie curie but no
and then
how did you like the actual day-to-day
was it you'd sit and read and then
keep it all in a spreadsheet or what was
the basic all of those things so for i
was on sabbatical the first year so i
just didn't even get out of my pajamas i
would get up in the morning and start
reading
read and read and read i had
spreadsheets i had dry erase boards i
was drawing maps between people so that
i could do every pairwise comparison you
go through this process of identifying
themes and then one of the key things
you have to do is when you think you
have a theme you go through and you try
to disprove it so you try to find the
exception to the rule to see if maybe
it's just a spurious theme because the
last thing you want to do is sucker
yourself into believing something that's
really just maybe a coincidence
so in the book i really only talk about
themes
everything that i talk about in the book
is exhibited by at least seven out of
the eight innovators most of them are
exhibited by all of the innovators uh
the exceptions there the two cases where
it's on
where it's seven not eight out of the
innovators are actually really
interesting and of themselves maybe
we'll end up talking about that yeah i'm
remembering the edison one but not the
other one so yes yeah
so
what you came up with is basically five
kind of
internal traits
and then a couple of external factors
right
and what i was thinking is let's
quickly go through because that's sort
of the meat of this book
these traits let's quickly go through
the five and then go back to them and so
number one a sense of separateness yeah
what does that mean i'm going to say one
thing real quick too uh as an academic
i'm careful about the word trait because
the psychologists have a pretty specific
meaning of what you can call a trait so
i tend to say characteristics but it
says traits right on the cover so um
okay sense of separateness
all of the innovators except benjamin
franklin exhibited this really strong
sense of separateness where they felt
socially disconnected they felt detached
from the world they didn't feel like
they belonged to it and as a result its
rules didn't apply to them we're going
to come back to it but i want to quickly
go through these and then we'll spend
more time on each one cool so sense of
separateness one number two extreme
confidence yeah and actually a specific
form of confidence so they weren't
always sort of globally confident i
think if you met marie curie you might
not have concluded she was globally
confident but self-efficacy is is
task-related confidence where you have
faith in your ability to overcome
obstacles and achieve your goals and a
person with extreme self-efficacy will
take on things that other people would
think were impossible which we see a lot
over and over again in the innovators
number one sense of separateness number
two extreme confidence number three the
creative mind okay so this is um it's an
amalgamation of things in that chapter
this chapter uh which i focus a lot on
nikola tesla in this chapter really
highlights
the connections between intelligence and
creativity and also why there is this
association between genius and madness
uh there will be we'll get back to that
and tesla okay
fine
number four what i did i grabbed this i
had this crazy idea that it would be
good to get them all in everybody's
heads yeah before we go back to them
number four a higher purpose yeah
idealism i guess yeah so seven out of
the eight innovators were
fiercely idealistic they're pursuing a
goal that they see as intrinsically
noble and honorable
and it drives them not money
you know
not fame a lot of them sacrificed their
health their reputation their families
their leisure everything in pursuit of
this goal because it was an ideal and
the exception was edison
number five driven to work not like in a
car but um
although some might have been i don't
know yeah
they all uh
loved to work none more so maybe than
edison i often relate edison to a border
collie and if any of you know dogs i'm a
dog person border collies are known for
being just incredible work animals
because they get such joy out of herding
sheep in fact they'll hurt anything
they'll hurt cats and children and
chickens and
and you don't have to train them you
don't have to reward them they do it
because they love it and as a saying
among dog people is if you don't give a
border collie a job it'll come up with
its own and you will not like it but all
of the people in the set were like this
they were happiest when they were
working hard
so a sense of separateness extreme
confidence the creative mind a higher
purpose driven to work so let's go back
to the separateness especially because
in innovation it seems like so much of
the talk in recent years has been about
group yeah the power of groups the power
of collaboration
yeah i have to say that um this is a
really surprising finding for me in
particular because a lot of the work
i've done is on collaboration i do work
on networks and everybody in networks
believes that social networks are hugely
important not only for developing ideas
but for implementing ideas and getting
them diffused and so how could it
possibly be that all of these serial
breakthrough innovators didn't have
strong social networks at all they were
actually very disconnected uh and it
turns out
it's actually the one who talked about
it the most is einstein albert einstein
could articulate it very clearly he
pointed out that first of all he said he
felt very detached from people even from
his family that he loved humanity but
not necessarily people individually
right he loved humanity as like a global
concept but uh but he felt separate from
people but he also felt it was very
important to
not become part of the herd and to think
independently and he believed that his
detachment and sense of separateness
well on the one hand
meant that he was maybe a little less
genial than some people and maybe there
was a twinge of melancholy in his words
about that
it made him able to reject assumptions
that held other people back it made him
able to challenge received wisdom and
it's hugely responsible for his ability
to cast off newtonian concepts that kept
poincare and lorenz from from making the
advances that he made so being separate
enabled these people to challenge rules
do things that other people thought were
wrong sometimes or thought were
impossible they were often
often stuck with them even when other
people argued against them they were
fundamentally unreasonable people but as
george bernard shaw points out all
progress comes from the unreasonable man
so we can see that very clearly in the
unreasonableness we can see it in elon
musk today we can see with these jobs
you think about
tesla versus
jobs and musk were actually able to get
a bunch of other people to help them
realize
yeah they were very separate and very
different and hard to get along with in
some ways but
they had this ability to make things
happen whereas tesla i think struggled
with that his whole life nikola tesla
yeah for sure nikola tesla worked mostly
alone mostly at night and other you know
his greatest inventions ended up being
taken off by other people well
yeah except that we're you know we're
still using ac electrical right that
were developed by nikola tesla some
people don't know that much about this
is uh
nikola tesla right up there he not only
invented uh ac electrical systems
pretty much all of them he also invented
wireless communication which was for
years attributed to google elmo marconi
and then it finally came out in a big
court case and they realized that
guglielmo marconi had basically ripped
off tesla he also invented lighting
systems and the first remote-controlled
robots
he he i actually think that he of
everybody on here was the smartest one
his mind was like a human computer-aided
design system he had this incredible
photographic memory so much so that he
often thought he was having
hallucinations because he would see
things in front of him because of his
memory and he could build something a
machine in his mind and turn it and run
it notice it was wobbling a little bit
adjust it turn it refine it fix it and
when he was completely done he would put
it into physical form and it would work
perfectly
i mean and and while you're inclined to
doubt that many people witnessed him
doing all kinds of advanced calculus and
physics in real time in his head didn't
have to write anything down just a
brilliant problem he had a lab like a
block from here or a couple blocks from
here yes the lab of his that burnt down
was either right here on west broadway
or laguardia place within about within a
block of this building was nikola
tesla's lab
so
bringing that back to
like a company that wants to
how do you put that together this this
fact that very often the best ideas come
individually with all this talk about
collaboration and needing to work
together yeah are there are there like
simple methods you can do to at least
come out of this absolutely so
i mean one of the implications of of one
of the things i talk a lot about in the
book and i can't take credit for this
because psychologists have actually
known this for years and it's amazing
that it hasn't really gotten out into
management but uh for instance
brainstorming groups don't work at all
and we've actually known this for a long
time but for some reason
it was so embedded in the norms that
organizations ever since alex osborne
wrote a book in 1956 and said that
groups were better for creativity we
bought into that and now it's almost
heresy to argue that they don't work and
even when i presented to my department
once and i said brainstorming groups
don't work people looked at me a little
bit horrified because we like to do
everything in teams we believe that
teams are very important but the problem
is the teams may be important for some
things they're not great for creativity
they're not great for a number of ideas
quality of ideas novelty of ideas and
the reason is that when you get together
in a group first of all you might not
want to put your craziest stuff out
there right you might feel shy about
sharing it we call that evaluation
apprehension that one's pretty obvious
the second one which is really
fascinating is called production
blocking and it means that while i'm
talking first of all you're not talking
but you're actually not even really
thinking i'm hijacking your thought
process i'm bringing you over to my
ideas while i'm talking it's hard for
you to elaborate your ideas while i'm
talking which means that when people are
working together they're losing stuff
and then the third piece which the
psychologist the psychology field hasn't
really talked about much yet but you
really understand it when you start to
study musk and jobs is that when people
are in groups a lot of people want to
avoid conflict a lot of people struggle
with conflict so they make concessions
so they sort of sand off all the sharp
corners of their idea and you end up
with this this compromise thing which
isn't the beautiful bold unusual and
unreasonable idea that you started with
so first of all that means let people
work alone first and then at some point
bring them together at some point you
can bring them together but you got to
make sure that they've already committed
to ideas developed amount they should
feel no fear they should be encouraged
to be weird and unorthodox and to make
uh
bold hypotheses you have to find a way
to signal a very high tolerance for
failure and a very high tolerance for
unconventionality and weirdness
so the next characteristic um
extreme confidence i mean that initially
sounds like especially
lately for some reason there's been a
lot of talk about the dunning-kruger
effect which is um
people who have very low abilities
thinking they're brilliant um how do how
do you
clearly these people were
very confident about themselves and they
were brilliant yeah how do you separate
that how do you figure out
even internally
yeah
so you know there's a strong selection
bias on these people and that all the
people i studied were
geniuses they were demonstrably geniuses
in fact when i first went into this
project i actually didn't think steve
jobs would turn out to be a genius but
steve jobs tested at the 10th grade
level when he was in fourth grade his
school recommended he'd be advanced two
grades his family said socially he
wasn't ready for that so they only
advanced him one grade and so uh he was
he was basically declared a genius by
the age of fourth grade but um how do
you tell if someone's just
confident versus if someone's smart or
yeah i guess that i guess because you're
right there are probably millions and
millions of people who possess the
extreme confidence that you describe
here it's just they're not combined with
all the other things
yeah you need that that
you know i had the confidence thing is
interesting because
efficacy self-efficacy which is that
task related confidence
it's not valuable it's not just viable
for innovation it's valuable for a lot
of things it's valuable for productivity
it's valuable for a sense of well-being
like it's a trait that we should
actively try to build in people because
it's it's a powerful empowering trait
and you can you can build it you can
build it in children you can build it in
employees you can even build it in
yourself
and the easiest way to all the the most
effective way to build it is early wins
so when you experience this early win of
doing something that you weren't sure
you could do and maybe there's obstacles
but you stick with it and you solve it
that ends up sending a very strong
signal to your to your mind that you can
overcome obstacles to achieve your goals
and in each of these innovators lives
they have these early wins and they talk
about how important it was how at that
moment they knew what they could do they
they had this incredible confidence
steve jobs talks a lot about how
building the blue boxes with woz
was a crucial moment he said without
that we we discovered what we could do
and suddenly we knew we could do so much
and he said these were the boxes that
allow you to scam a t yeah to hack the
phone system
they developed a system to hack the
phone system and he said he said if
there had been no blue boxes there would
have been no apple so that early win was
really important
but it has direct implications for how
you manage people and how you manage
kids like if you're if someone is
struggling with something a little bit
sometimes our instinct is to jump in and
help them which is good for social
bonding and for signaling and nurturing
relationship
but it undermines self-efficacy a lot of
times you're better off saying i have
faith in you you got this you can do it
stick with it as long as you think it's
something they have a chance of solving
you should probably let them work it
through and solve it on their own
because they'll build
self-efficacy
and then there's there's another way you
can build self-efficacy that's that's
even easier do you wanna know what that
one is sure okay so it's interesting
humans are an interdependent animal
we're a species that relies on
interdependence and we're wired for
social learning which means that you
don't have to actually go out and try
berries to discover if they'll kill you
you learn from seeing if they killed
anyone else right you learn about what
you were likely to be able to jump over
or what you can do by observing what
other people can do you're wired that
way that's your nature and so we can
actually build self-efficacy through
hero stories so when we have people
uh like we do this in school with kids
when we have them learn about someone
that they can identify with in some way
not some superhero but someone they can
identify with
struggling through some problem and then
overcoming it and succeeding they also
learn something about themselves at that
moment so you can build self-efficacy
that way
so did does star wars count or is that
too superhero
star wars
probably counts yeah yeah
um
the creative mind i mean
it sounds kind of broad but there's some
specific
things about how these people's brains
work yeah i'd say the two biggest things
in that uh
that i found in
in that chapter that i talk about in
that chapter the first one is the
relationship between intelligence and
creativity and we've always known that
there was some relationship but it's
been unclear because it's it's not the
case that all geniuses will be creative
and it's also not the case that you have
to be a genius to be creative or that
all creative people are geniuses and yet
there's some relationship and when you
when you um when you study it at a
neuroscience level what you end up
realizing is that
first of all a slightly elevated
dopamine causes you to experience
divergent thinking it enhances your
defocused attention it reduces your
ability to screen out stimuli it's
called latent uh latent stimuli
inhibition so if you have modestly
elevated dopamine you feel
more creative you're likely to be more
creative it's actually the reason that
parkinson's patients
someone told me a few years ago someone
came to me one of my colleagues joe
porack and said did you hear that
they've discovered that parkinson's
people people with parkinson's are
actually
much more creative they suddenly
discover all these artistic abilities
and they have all these talents that
they never knew they had and at the time
i was studying nikola tesla and i was
thinking a lot about dopamine and i said
at that moment it's the levodopa it's
not the parkinson's it's the levodopa
they're treating them with because you
treat people with parkinson's with
synthetic dopamine and sure enough about
six months later they figured out it was
the levodopa but uh so this dopamine
elevation it makes you more creative
but it also enhances working memory and
executive control so people with
modestly elevated
dopamine are likely to not only attend
to stimuli and be better at defocused
attention they can retain more of it in
working memory so it actually enhances
things that look a lot like intelligence
how do we elevate our dopamine without
getting parkinson's disease yeah well so
elevating your dopamine isn't so if you
elevate your dopamine chronically you
don't run out and take levodopa because
if you elevate your dopamine too much or
chronically or you stimulate those
dopamine receptors which is exactly
what's happening with meth or cocaine or
even sex uh
my kid's here so i probably should have
made that reference but um
but if your dopamine is too high too
much your brain which is this very smart
animal of its own starts to down
regulate your dopamine receptors it
turns them off which is exactly why a
meth addict when they get off of meth
looks a lot like a parkinson's patient
they don't want to move they don't want
to talk they don't experience pleasure
from anything so you don't want to
elevate your dopamine that much but if
you just want to elevate it modestly
like a good cup of coffee or run
or sex
those things all modestly elevate your
dopamine
and so that was one the dopamine level
was one key what's the other one so the
other one turns out to be dopamine
related too when you study nikola tesla
nikola tesla
he ends up he has so many of these
traits but turned up to a level so much
higher than the other guys i i my spinal
tap references that he has these
straights turned up to 11.
and you notice things in him that you
then start looking for in the other
innovators and then you find them and
they're things that nobody's even talked
about so
when you study nicola tesla it's very
very clear that he has some form of
dopamine dysregulation he's manic a lot
of the time he almost never sleeps he
sleeps two hours a night if he sleeps at
all he has a lot of flowing rushing
thoughts he's acutely sensitive to
stimuli like like the sound of a fly
landing on a table hurts his ears
and lights hurt his eyes so he tries to
shut off all the lights he's acutely
sensitive he's also he also has signs of
obsessive compulsive disorder so he's um
anything spherical makes him feel like a
sense of abhorrence and like if a woman
wore pearls he couldn't even be near her
he had to calculate the cubic root of
his food every night and if it didn't
divide exactly by three he couldn't eat
it and he used to walk around buildings
three times before during that problem
with that too yeah so in him you see all
these diagnostic criteria that he's got
these imbalances and one of them is this
dopamine he had really high elevated
dopamine
and he had mania but then when you go
back and you look at the other
innovators everybody but einstein slept
significantly less than the average
person so marie curie and uh
where where are they all here so marie
curie and thomas edison slept about four
hours a night dean caiman sleeps four
hours a night benjamin franklin slept
five hours a night steve jobs was
estimated to sleep between five and six
hours a night elon musk says he sleeps
six and a half hours a night
the national average in the united
states is eight and a half hours the
average globally for developed countries
the one that's lowest is japan and
that's still seven and a half hours so
most of these guys slept significantly
less than a regular person because i
always like that's the staple of
ceo profiles in business magazines
really they don't talk about how they
say and i always wonder if they're just
idiots and they're going to
kill themselves because they don't get
enough sleep or is there just this group
of the population that just doesn't need
it i think it's very hard on your body
to not get enough sleep it can be very
hard on your mind but what you also have
to remember is it's not that they slept
less and became innovative
they slept less because their dopamine
was elevated when your dopamine is
elevated and your manic you're not tired
so an insomniac doesn't sleep but they
feel bad right they feel tired they wish
they were sleeping a manic person
doesn't sleep and doesn't feel tired at
all and that's what you know these
people i think a lot of them have a
little bit of mania
all right
there was one other thing in that um
chapter that you described that just
i'd never thought about thinking that
way and it's that we all when we're
thinking about things follow association
paths where we're thinking about oh and
that reminds us that no one minds that
and one of the things that's different
about these people who are very creative
and good at it it's not they they go
down the same path they just go much
faster yeah than normal people faster
and further faster well yeah so by the
time you know five minutes later they're
already moved on beyond the basic things
and starting to move into the other
thing so it's not this like radically
different way of thinking it's just they
can make the connections faster yeah and
that goes back to working memory and
executive control you know they say elon
musk kimball musk says that elon musk
always is thinking 10 steps out like he
just does it automatically that's how
his mind works
uh and having that sort of long path of
association means he's gonna see the
world differently than you do he's gonna
see the implications of something
you know what happens next what happens
next what happens next what happens next
what happens next or what caused that
what caused that what caused that what
caused that he's going to get the bigger
picture quicker because he does 10 steps
out
well elon's a good person to go to the
next the next characteristic is higher
purpose idealism and
elon musk is somebody who i think
there's a
there's just a lot of um
differing opinions about is he this what
is what is this guy doing is he just
trying to
do a big snow job on all of us or is he
this guy trying to save the world and so
what like what is
he's idealist what what is his higher
purpose
he's
so interesting right anyone if you
actually take the time to study elon
musk
there is no way you will come away from
that thinking that he's about the money
he is not about the money at all he
you know remember he sold his first
video game when he was 12. he taught
himself the program at 10 and sold his
first video game at 12. and today if a
12 year old writes a video game maybe
you're not that impressed but this was
the early 80s when you were having to
learn basic right when the screens were
in monochrome and it was all text based
can you even begin to imagine teaching
yourself the program at the age of 12
back in the early 80s but so he he sells
blastar he ends up forming a uh internet
company in college that he ends up
selling to compaq for many millions of
dollars then he starts a financial
payments company part of which ends up
becoming paypal which he was sold to
ebay and by the time he sells that
company he's got 180 million dollars he
doesn't need money anymore he's not
about you know at that point he could
have just you know bought an island and
drank mojitos uh but he asked himself
what can i do that will really make a
meaningful difference in the world and
he looked around and he heard that nasa
was not going to take us to mars and he
was he thought what what do you mean
nasa's not going to take us to mars and
so he rolls up his sleeves he's like
okay well i'll just have to take us
there ourselves myself and um
his whole purpose and the reason he got
involved in tesla was because he
believes that we're gonna run out of
energy so he wants to get us onto a
renewable energy alternative the reason
he originally wrote up the business plan
for solarcity some people don't realize
that he was the one who originally came
up with the idea of solarcity and then
handed it off to his cousins to to
develop into a company was to create
renewable energy and then mars is the
backup plan because once he thinks if
some cataclysmic event comes and and our
planet is ruined the only way the
species will be preserved is if we have
a colony on mars so he really wants to
get us to mars and he wants it so badly
that he won't take spacex public because
he knows if he took spacex public a
board of directors would probably force
him to make some changes that would
lessen the chance of getting to mars so
a like a feverishly idealistic person
what what were some of the other big
ideals that these people
had so
nikola tesla believed that if he could
invent a free energy system he could
eliminate all human uh toil human
physical work and that therefore we
could focus on more creative endeavors
he also really believed this was his
lifelong ambition was to develop a
global wireless communication system
because he believed that if we could
talk to each other around the world it
would obviate war and i think he'd be a
little disappointed to find out that
that has turned out not to be true yeah
because when i read that i was thinking
yeah that's ridiculous on the other hand
i guess we've had
fewer wars than
we did before i don't know the problem
is other things changed at the same time
that that enabled war yep um you want
some other idea yeah yeah sure okay so
benjamin franklin
keenly idealistic person developed a 13
virtues of life that he published and
and had people follow his whole goal was
around industriousness he was a strong
believer in industriousness and in a a
egalitarian and free america he became
so committed to that ideal that he ended
up severing ties with his son because
his son was a british loyalist so he
chose his ideal of a free america over
his son
uh marie curie let's talk about dean
cayman for a minute so dean caiman this
is a guy
it said that he didn't technically
finish high school he definitely didn't
finish college but he was a tinkerer and
when he was a high school kid he started
tinkering and he was so effective at it
that he got the contract to light some
of the major museums around new york he
also uh i think maybe around the age of
20 got the contract to do the ball drop
on new year's and
so he's a tinker he's a talented
talented electronics person totally
self-taught
and then at some point he
saw a person having to go in for kidney
dialysis his brother's a doctor and he
saw that you have to be connected to a
large machine and you have to be there
for hours and it's miserable right and
if you it disrupts your job it disrupts
everything about your life it's he found
he thought it disrupts your dignity and
he thought
i can solve that problem and so he
invented the world's first portable
dialysis machine then he invented the
world's first portable drug infusion
pump then he saw someone in a wheelchair
one day struggling to get up a curb
and he just felt so bad for that person
so he started developing the ibot
mobility wheelchair which can climb
stairs and it can also stand up on two
wheels and balance so that you can be
eye to eye because he felt like that was
a very important part of restoring
someone's dignity was to enable them to
stand up and look people eye to eye and
it was it turns out that balancing
something on two wheels is really
complicated and a lot of people told
them it wasn't possible that wheels have
to be able to adjust and spin back and
forth very quickly but it's that
technology that led to segway
so his ideal was to reduce human
suffering
now the the non-idealist of the bunch is
edison yeah
you looked and looked and you just
couldn't find any i looked and i looked
i really thought surely i was gonna find
an idealistic edison somewhere and i
gotta tell you there's
there's there were
you know you follow a little in love
with anybody that you study intensely
but i had a very conflicted relationship
with edison
it sounds like we actually had he uh
he he electrocuted a lot of dogs which
really bothered and also a cow and a
horse and not the elephant that's a hoax
don't believe that he electrocuted the
elephant but he did electrocute over two
dozen dogs he would give boys uh if they
came in with a dog off the street he'd
give them an orange and he did it just
to prove that ac electricity was was too
powerful to be safe which was tesla's
electrical current so that people would
adopt dc electrical current which was
his so i had this really conflicted
relationship with edison but i thought
surely i was going to find the idealism
in him somewhere and i and i he actually
has something close to an autobiography
that was written in 1919 most people
don't realize that and it's a big tomb
of work so if you ever really want to
know him you could start in on that but
it's it's hard it's hard work reading
that one
but i found a quote in like a
magazine or a newspaper published in the
early 1900s
that just really relieved
any search propensity any any
just relieved me from my search he
basically wrote
i don't like to think about the
highfalutin things i'm not interested in
those big ideals i stay pretty close to
the ground i'm a practical man that
thinking is for other people so he's
telling you in his own words he's not an
idealist
but he loved to work he said work made
the earth a paradise for me and i never
intend to retire
and some people assume that edison was
like a very materialistic man because he
liked to win and he liked to get patents
but one thing that's worth knowing about
him because he did he did screw over
tesla at one point a lot of people
begrudge him that as they as they will
should but he also got screwed over by
jp morgan and the other financiers of
the time because he had helped found the
company that became general electric and
it was general electric edison and they
maneuvered him right out of that and
took his name off the moniker
and he subsequently basically lost all
the money from that company and at one
point i think it was uh probably francis
upton or maybe charles batchelor who
said to him
well do you realize that you've lost the
four million that you made from all of
your electrical enterprise
and he thought about it for a minute and
then he shrugged and he said yeah but we
had a good time doing it didn't we
well because like early on his goal was
just to get independent enough to be
able to work on whatever he wanted to
work on he did not like to have a boss
that's what he ended up getting to do
yeah he wanted to be autonomous he had
fierce need for autonomy that a lot of
these guys have that need for autonomy
and the hard work part i mean on the one
hand yeah of course they got to work
hard on the other hand again there's
lots of talk lately about hey maybe if
you don't work so many hours you can be
more productive and the slog gets people
down but these people basically worked
all the time yeah it's funny because
it's a friend of mine morton hanson just
published great at work and a big theme
in that book is
that you shouldn't work so hard
but what morton's theme really is is
that we create a lot of busy work for
ourselves and we work on things that
don't matter very much
i hope i get this right because
if i don't get it right i'm going to pay
for it but he he thinks he should work
on things that really matter focus on
those things and not all the other stuff
what you have to understand about these
people is that they were always working
and it was on something that really
really mattered in fact this goes back
to the very first thing i noticed about
steve jobs and dean cayman strange
little quirk that they both have in
common they both wore the exact same
clothes every single day
and marie curie also wore the same
clothes every single day and albert
einstein was known to wear the same
clothes every single day and in albert
einstein's time in marie curie's time
you know people didn't have as many
clothes and thomas edison wore the same
basic suit all the time but in steve
jobs time in dean cayman's time it's
hard to understand why they would wear
the same clothes every day
but then you have to remember they
didn't care what other people thought of
them because the rule they were separate
right they were socially separate so the
rules that are applying to all of you
don't apply to them so that need to
dress in different clothes goes away and
at the same time
they're focused on something else more
important and when somebody asked dean
cayman one time why do you wear the same
clothes every day and he looked down at
his clothes he always wears a blue work
shirt and jeans and boots
and he said well i wear work clothes
when i'm working and if i'm awake i'm
working
i mean there's also been this discussion
i mean i think partly because so many
people saw the example of jobs of just
you you remove one decision in the
morning
every decision takes a little bit out of
you and that's removing that i mean i
think like obama when he was president
had this rack of identical suits yeah
put him on and and well and
jack dorsey at twitter total jobs
imitator uh does the same and elizabeth
holmes elizabeth holmes that
but it made her get to work quicker so
in that sense it worked so we're gonna
go to questions in a little bit one
thing so where are the microphones how
does that work they're back there okay
so but we're going to talk a little bit
but start thinking about things you
might want to ask
um so
those were the the five
individual characteristics and i'm just
going to do it again a sense of
separateness extreme confidence you're
going to have to buy the book if you
tell them all this overnight i don't
know i think yeah
you've got a higher purpose driven to
work
and then
the other two
sort of chapters about
these people were kind of about the
external factors yeah
timing
and resources basically
and i mean one of the things you look up
here and it's a bunch of white guys
except marie curie and actually
the fact that she
was able to do this it's an interesting
set of so she was she's from poland
right right well that wasn't so she grew
up in the area that was occupied by
russia and we're at a time when the
russian czar was trying to eliminate all
the stages of polish heritage you
couldn't
you couldn't learn polish literature
history in school you couldn't even use
the polish language in school they were
trying to russify that entire area and
um
you know she came from a family of
intellectuals the shlakka class and her
both her father and her mother were
teachers her father was a professor uh
and they believed very firmly in
education but
one of the things that really made a
difference in marie curie's life is that
this movement came about called polish
positivism so
poland had tried to fight against russia
initially with military means with war
and they got trounced they lost really
badly and millions lots of lives were
lost
and then they realized we can't fight
russia that way they're too big and
strong we'll never be able to defeat
them so they decided we will save poland
by
by preserving polig
heritage through science we will make
sure that polls are smart and educated
and contribute to science and are
remembered that way and they had this
movement where they said every poll must
be educated even the women and this is
at a time when most of europe didn't
allow women to go into higher education
women didn't tend to get educated beyond
the age of 14 and most universities in
europe didn't allow women in but polish
positivism said that women
like all polls had to be educated
and marie curie was very committed to
this class her name wasn't marie curie
back then as was maria skodovska
she became involved in this thing called
the flying university which was a secret
covert school program that would be held
in basements and in churches or in your
back room of your house
that would secretly educate women women
educating other women so she was running
with the group of the smartest and
fiercest women of her time
helping educate other women
and then when she was she was a
brilliant brilliant person she learned
to read well ahead of all of her her
siblings who were older and and she was
studying math and science but again she
wasn't allowed to go to university in
warsaw so she worked as a governess and
scraped up a little money and traveled
to france alone i mean her sister was
had gotten there a few years ahead of
her and enrolled in the sorbonne and
scraped by a meager existence and got
her phd at the sorbonne
you know overcoming remarkable odds so
once you hear all that story
you suddenly realize well i see why
there aren't more women because what she
had to do to become a woman of science
was intense right i also studied grace
hopper who was a little bit later in
time grace hopper didn't meet the
criteria of serial breakthrough
innovator but
another important innovator she invented
she invented computer programming
language and she talks a lot about the
fact that women were not welcome in
business and science during her time and
this is like world war ii that that era
even during her time women weren't
welcome in business and in science so
but but what war broke out and she
joined the navy and she became a naval
admiral and she invented computer
programs uh in the navy and because she
was an admiral
hp and ibm and dec those companies would
talk to her because her uniform and
military protocol essentially neutered
her right it made her gender go away
right
so
you know both of these cases really
illustrate that women were at a severe
disadvantage to get into education and
to get the kind of education you need
and to get into science as were people
of color
as uh for a long period were jews also
so a lot of hurdles and when you're
looking at a sample of people who make
it onto most famous innovator lists
you're looking in a long time window
when only the very end of that time
window from your side over here very end
of that time window
women would have had any possibility so
marie curie was really the um
an outlier in that respect right
anyone have a question we have mike here
yeah here's somebody
thank you
how did you come up with the eight
people that you did and
you know most of them are americans did
you not look at europeans as much yeah i
most of them are they're not mostly
american actually so
elon is south african uh marie curie is
was polish uh nicholas tesla was he's
from croatia but he's from serbian
descent i would count jobs as american
albert einstein was uh he denounced his
german
citizenship benjamin franklin was
american and thomas edison was basically
american although his family spent part
of their life in canada and then dean
came in as american
but
this goes back to as an empirical
researcher i wanted to get myself out of
the process as much as possible because
i thought i could inadvertently
introduce bias
if i was selecting people like people
would come to me and say you should look
at william shockley he was a weird guy
i'm like now i can't look at william
shockley because he just told me he's a
weird guy right you can't select on on
those variables so what i did was i had
these criteria where everybody had to be
on multiple towards the top when i buy
towards the top like within the first 20
on the top of multiple most famous
inventor most famous innovator lists so
you're letting the world identify the
people they see as being most important
they had to be serial breakthrough
innovators which means they had to have
really big
innovations more than one in their
lifetime preferably their many across
their lifetime because
if somebody only has one big innovation
it's very hard to separate person from
context right right time right place can
give you one invention
it doesn't tend to give you a lifetime
of invention
so they had to be serial breakthrough
innovators they had to be people about
whom there were multiple biographies and
first-person accounts i wanted to hear
their voice in their own words
not like literally hearing but like
written i read the letters and the there
were video transcripts from a lot of
them
marie curie actually has a not only
several biographies of her but one's
written by her daughter which is a very
poignant biography so there had to be
have multiple biographies about them so
that you're not unduly influenced by one
biographer
and in the end also i found that there
was a lot of dissenses about
innovators in fields like art or music
because that hedonic
taste element meant that people had very
heterogeneous tastes and also people
felt that fads like once you're famous
you might stay famous so i ended up
deciding to use only people from science
and technology because i felt like it
was easier
to objectively ascertain that there was
a breakthrough innovation that the
criteria were a little bit more object
not purely objective but more objective
and there was definitely much more
consensus like if you look at the lists
of technology innovators you get the
same people over and over and over again
there's lots of consensus about it and
then when i finally had a set and it was
frankly all white men and marie curie
then i picked people from different time
periods and different industry sectors
so that you know you didn't want to just
take everybody who came out during the
i.t bloom right and you didn't want to
take everybody just from the
electrification era although you could
have there were a lot of people during
that time you want people from different
time periods in order to again separate
person from context
hi um so i recently was listening to a
series that freakonomics podcasted on
ceos and one of the episodes covered
different research studies that have
been done trying to find commonalities
between ceos
they didn't really have a they had a
hard time finding commonalities and
there were actually a lot of diverse
characteristics
um what do you think makes
being a good leader which i'm sort of
putting in the ceo category yeah
different from being an innovator why
why was it maybe a little bit um maybe
easier to find the commonalities there
although it sounds like your research
was not easy by any means but like why
why does that
sort of provide a unique set the way
that just good old-fashioned good
leadership is maybe a little bit more
variable yeah so
you know
some of these guys were ceos but not
necessarily ceos that we admired for
their ceoing
if we can turn that into a verb
ceos
to be a good leader you have to have
good people skills people good people
skills are something that
are very valuable in a huge range of
applications in your life so it now
becomes harder to separate ceos from
people who are successful in just a
non-ceo roles right
it's probably also
there's probably also a lot of ceos with
a lot of variance and the trick would be
identifying the people that you think
like to do this kind of study you'd have
to pick people that everybody agreed
were the best ceos of all time right
like how could could we identify the
eight best ceos of all time and if we
did an in-depth study of those people
where we developed biographies of each
one and a pairwise case comparison of
everyone and studied them really
rigorously
we would probably find some
commonalities i bet you'll find high
self-efficacy in the best ceos too for
instance high self-efficacy is a is a
trait you're gonna find in a lot of
people who are really driven like
whenever you see someone who's very
driven and maybe uh
does things that other people would uh
find too hard or or too scary there's
probably going to be a self-efficacy
part of that story uh but it just hasn't
really been looked at that closely i
don't know how they structured their
study there's probably lots more people
lots more people so you end up with this
thin layer again of what's in common
thank you other questions
yes
who's got
oh up here yep
hi i have a question about the
connection between uh their success and
education yeah um so some of these
people are often pointed to as you don't
need higher education to be extremely
successful um in your field in fact it
might have the opposite effect and
education actually might suppress uh the
creativity portion of
the of the process so i'm wondering
among these people what percentage
were you know highly educated formally
which percentage were not and whether
there was any connection between it and
their success in their innovation i'm
really glad you asked that question
because it's one of the big takeaways
from the book i have to say that as a
business school professor
you expect to hear that access to
capital mattered a lot and education
mattered a lot because if those two
things don't matter then my role is a
little bit uh in doubt but um
all of these people started with no
money at all in fact it's some famous
stories that are just like benjamin
franklin arrived in new york with enough
money for exactly two rolls of bread
nikola tesla arrived in new york he got
his everything stolen on the boat so he
arrived in new york with four cents and
a poem in his pocket
uh elon musk you know came over to
canada at the age of 17 against his
parents wishes and worked on farms in a
boiler room to put himself to school
none of them started a lot of money and
most of them here's this is an
interesting thing a lot of them had far
less formal education than you would
expect given their fields and even the
ones that had education a lot of them
had a conflicted relationship with
education so if we start at the top elon
musk he had has two undergraduate
degrees but he says he never went to
class he just showed up to take the
exams he
he he was only interested in classes he
thought were relevant to his purpose he
didn't think he should have to take the
other classes and so those annoyed him
marie curie i'm going to leave her out
she was an exceptional student the whole
way in she's the exception here but
nikola tesla was actually a brilliant
student but
became addicted to gambling and dropped
out of school
steve jobs you know dropped out of
school but said it was the best thing
that ever happened to him because he
stayed on campus and started taking the
classes he wanted to take
albert einstein had this really
difficult relationship with his
professors got a phd but but was i think
the bottom of his class when he
graduated and very very conflicted
talked a lot through his life about how
school can destroy the creativity and
independence of a person and and really
in some ways he resented
the educational process and but he was
self-taught and i'm gonna go back come
back to that so give me a minute
benjamin franklin had almost no
schooling as you know like he
really very very little schooling
because his parents couldn't afford it
and they apprenticed him to be a printer
with indentured them him to be a printer
with his brother
thomas edison was born with this
abnormally large head and so doctors
thought he was fragile that there was
actually something wrong with them so
they initially told his parents he
better not send that kid to school
and then at one point when he was about
seven or eight he they enrolled him in
school but he was distractible and
hyperactive and he overheard one of the
teachers calling him adult and he went
home to tell his mother that somebody
had called him adult which means you
know scatterbrained and can't
concentrate
and his mother
got so mad that she marched down to the
the school and told the teacher this boy
has more brains than you yourself and
took him out of school and homeschooled
him from that point on so he had just a
couple of months of schooling
uh some of you have read a story about a
letter that's actually a hoax the the
letter but
but he did have almost no schooling
totally self-taught by the time he was
12 he had read all the great physics
texts all the great philosophy texts in
the library his between his mother and
him they just sat and read all these
incredibly sophisticated books and then
dean came in as i mentioned also not a
good student
but
so you're tempted to think education
doesn't matter maybe education hurts
that's not the case
what happened was that these people
consumed vast amounts of education they
were ravenous for books they were always
teaching themselves but they needed to
consume education at their own pace in
their own direction in their own format
right the the structure of a standard
curriculum just chafed them it was like
having their wings held in by a cage
they needed to fly down paths of their
own choosing and they all did right so
elon musk
he was an intense reader he read every
book in the public library in his town
and then he started in on the
encyclopedia and committed large parts
of it to memory
and he said in a rolling stone interview
recently i was raised by books books and
then my parents
so education mattered but it it was not
standardized standardized education
didn't suit them they needed
personalized self-driven education
but at the same time they were all
looking for
what are the most important texts read i
mean they weren't like going off on some
loopy whatever they were mostly actually
really good at picking okay this is what
i have to read to learn how to shoot a
rocket off and bring it back to earth
right whatever else right exactly yes so
it's like this respect for expertise
just not for
the way classes work yeah yeah i have to
say i've been a professor now for
24 years
and
students are heterogeneous right they
don't think they're heterogeneous when
they answer their evaluation forms they
act as if they think the entire class is
just like them but they're wrong because
they're all taking wildly different
stances on what worked in the class for
them some people are more visual
learners and some people are more
auditory some people like a lot of
structure some people like a
freewheeling conversation some people
frankly would do better in an
environment with some ambient noise some
people need silence
right some people want to work in long
stretches some people need to work in
short fits and bursts so
you know i've been been writing about
this lately that i think that um the
challenge with standardized education is
that kids aren't standardized
okay we are done but we will be around
so people can ask questions this has
been really fun
i didn't get for a couple of times
so thank you both for really terrific
and thought-provoking conversation um we
have some gifts that i'm going to hand
to you in just a second as a token of
our appreciation
so join us now for the reception um you
can purchase books over there at the
table and then melissa will be signing
books in the back and don't forget that
the royalties from the books sold
tonight will go to stem kids nyc so
thank you very much for coming
[Applause]
you're watching book tv on c-span 2 with
top non-fiction books and authors every
weekend
book tv television